UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN FOR
MERGING SEA AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
ADHERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
AND COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. SENATORS AS A REMINDER
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN THE ELIMINATING OF ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE. BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT.
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE HE
REQUIRES PARLIAMENT'S ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USED USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHOWISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER ANDACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION- TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX EIGHT.
NINE FOUR ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND FOR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
SIGN A LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE
SHORT A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT ON IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE UN MUTED
YOU ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE DURING THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED. AND THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE JUSTIN TO THE
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
ACCORDINGLY. WE HAVE A SIX
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA- FOR
THE PUBLIC'S- INFORMATION FROM
MEMBERS FOR PARTICIPATION SB
THIRTY ONE BY- AUTHOR CURTIS HE
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING- THE BILL HAS BEEN
PULLED BY ALL THE AUTHOR AND IT
IS LIKELY THAT THE BILL WILL BE
HEARD AT A LATER DATE. BEFORE
WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION ON THE
BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WESSEL PRESIDENT WESSEL PRESENT.
SENATOR DOLLY THERE CENTER
DOLLY HERE. SENATOR BAKER HERE
SENATOR BAKER HERE. CENTREBOARD
THIS. SENATOR BRADFORD WILL
SENATE BRADFORD HERE. SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SENATOR GROW. SENATE APPROVED
HERE. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. SENATOR MEN
ENTER SENATOR MEN HERE. SENATOR
RUBIO. SENATOR RUBIO PRESENT.
SENATOR STERN. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SENATOR GONZALEZ HERE. TERRY
HAVE CORN. SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. NECKS WE WILL ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES THIS IS
CUSTOMARY EVERY OF EVERY TWO
YEARS- AND- THE RULES ARE
PRETTY MUCH OF- THE SAME EVERY
EVERY TWO YEARS FOR MY
KNOWLEDGE- IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION. THE COMMITTEE RULES
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE
SESSION. ARE ADOPTED. NOW WE
WILL ADDRESS THE CONSENT ITEMS
CAN I GET A MOVE MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB THREE
NINETY FOUR AND AS BEFORE
SEVENTY NINE SOME OF. HEY WE
HAVE A MOTION. THANK YOU CENTER.
CLLR COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WESSEL FIVE FOR WITH A ON.
SENATOR DOLLY. CENTER DOLLY HI.
SENATOR BAKER AYE SENATOR BAKER
HI. SENATE ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
PORTICI MEMBERS I'D REMIND
FOLKS TO PLEASE- SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE. SENATOR BRADFORD
HI. SENATOR BRADFORD HI.
SENATOR DOT. SENATOR EGGMAN.
SENATOR GONZALEZ I SENATOR
GONZALEZ I. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR GROW. ALL RIGHT. CENTER
GROVE HIGH. SENATE MCGUIRE.
SENATOR MAN. SENATE AMEND. THIS
IS FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CENTERMAN HI. SENATOR RUBIO HI
SENATOR MAIENSCHEIN SENATOR
RUBIO I. SENATOR STERN. OKAY
WELL THERE YOU HAVE NINE BUT
THE MAYONNAISE. HOW MANY DAYS
NINE NINE FORTY THAT'S ENOUGH
FOR THE BILL TO GET UP WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN ON ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS BUT I JUST WANNA REMIND
MEMBERS- TO TRY TO GET INTO A
HABIT EVERY TIME YOU EITHER
SPEAK FOR YOU VOTE PLEASE VOTE
INTO THE MIKE SO THAT WAY. NOT
ONLY CAN OUR- CLERK HERE YOU
PUT. THE PUBLIC AS WELL- NOW WE
ARE GONNA- MOVE OVER TO OUR
NEXT. PRESENTER CENTER SKINNER
ON S. B. EIGHTEEN THE BILL
RELATED TO GREEN. HYDROGEN
WELCOME CENTER SKINNER PLEASE
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CARE MEMBERS- FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. THE REALLY GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS RICHER OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS- SO APPRECIATE
THAT. HYDROGEN IS MOST OF US
KNOW IS THE MOST ABUNDANT
ELEMENT BASIC ELEMENT IN THE
UNIVERSE. AND IT IS POISED TO
HELP CALIFORNIA AND THE ENTIRE
WORLD MOVED TO A LOWER TO NO
CARBON ECONOMY. WHICH WE
DESPERATELY NEED. WHAT HYDROGEN
CAN DO IT IS. ONCE PRODUCED
THROUGH ELECTROLYSIS STORE
EXCESS RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY
GENERATED BY OUR SON OUR SOLAR
AND WIND INSTALLATIONS SO THAT
WE CAN THEN DEPLOY IT LATER. IT
CAN ALSO BE A- IT CAN. IN FACT
BE A THE PRODUCTION OF IT COULD
BE A PRODUCTIVE USE FOR THE
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION OF WASTE
WHICH IS WE KNOW PRODUCES
METHANE AND SUCH AND WE CAN USE
THAT NOTHING TO. POWER STEAM
REFORMATION OR GASIFICATION TO
PRODUCE HYDROGEN. AND THE OTHER
BENEFITS OF HYDROGEN IS THAT IT
CAN DECARBONISE DIFFICULT
SECTORS LIKE SHIPPING LONG HAUL
TRUCKING AIR TRAVEL SO MUCH AND
BECAUSE IT COULD POTENTIALLY
USE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE IT
PRESERVES WELL PAYING JOBS.
WHAT SB EIGHTEEN SPECIFICALLY
DOES IS IT VANCE'S GREEN
HYDROGEN BY ESTABLISHING A
DEFINITION SO FAR THE ONLY
DEFINITION WE HAVE BEEN CODE IS
FOR GREEN ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
SO THIS ADDS A DEFINITION OF
GREEN HYDROGEN. AND IT ASKS ARE
YOUR RESOURCES BOARD TO ADD
HYDROGEN TO THE SCOPING PLAN
SAID WE HAVE ANOTHER TOOL IN
OUR TOOL KIT. AND IT CLARIFIES
THE GREEN HYDROGEN IS A ZERO
CARBON RESOURCE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF OUR RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD AND
INTEGRATED INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLAN. IT REQUIRES OUR PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO ADD
GREEN HYDROGEN INTO. RICHARD
CONSIDERATIONS AROUND OUR
EXISTING ENERGY STORAGE
PROCUREMENT FIVE STATUTES SO
LET ME NOW TURN TO MY-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THERE'S
JANICE LAND FROM THE GREEN
HYDROGEN COALITION AND JAMIE
LEVIN FOR THE CENTER FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. MODERATOR CAN WE
ASK JANICE LYNN. TO SPEAK IF
SHE'S AVAILABLE THERE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO THINK
CAREFULLY SO AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE ENERGY COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER AND I'M THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION OR
GHC. FOR A FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
NONPROFIT WHOSE MISSION IS TO
ADVANCE GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION I'M- ASKING L. TO
ACCELERATE MULTI SECTORAL
DECARBONISATION. AS SENATOR
SKINNER MENTIONED GREEN
HYDROGEN IS TRULY A GAME
CHANGER IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE IT'LL
ENABLE THE DECARBONISATION OF
REALLY DIFFICULT TO DECARBONISE
FACTORSTHAT ARE NOT EASILY
ELECTRIFIED. AND IMPORTANTLY
AND AFFORDABLE AND RESPONSIBLE
TRANSITION OUR FIRST POSSIBLE
INTEREST OF TIME I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THREE KEY REASONS.
FIRST GREEN HYDROGEN IT'S A
GREAT WAY TO ELECTRIFYING AND
CARBONIZED FUEL SUPPLY. MEETING
AT SENATOR SKINNER MENTIONED WE
CAN CONVERT ARE ABUNDANT LOW
COST WIND AND SOLAR AND OTHER
AGRICULTURAL RESOURCES AND
OTHER WASTE PRODUCTS INTO A
FLEXIBLE ZERO CARBON FUEL THAT
CAN DISPLACING MANY FOSSIL FUEL
APPLICATIONS INCREASING.
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY.
SECONDLY CREATE HIGH WE CAN
REPAIR VALUABLE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR AFFORDABLE
ENERGY TRANSITION AS AN EXAMPLE
LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER
AND POWER IS IN THE PROCESS OF
CONVERTING ITS LAST REMAINING
COAL PLANTS I. P. P. LOCATED IN
CENTRAL UTAH. TO A COMBINED
CYCLE GREEN HYDROGEN GAS
TURBINE. I THINK HE WILL
COMMENCE OPERATIONS SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WITH A 30%
GREEN HYDROGEN LAND INCREASING
THAT PERCENTAGE 21100% ON OR
BEFORE TWENTY FORTY FIVE. I. P.
P. IS THE LARGEST GREEN
HYDROGEN PROJECT IN NORTH
AMERICA TODAY AND WILL ENABLE
YOUR PORTABLE DISPATCHABLE
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY AND
RELIABILITY FUTURE FOR THE
REFERENCE. RESIDENTS OF THAT
RIGHT. THIRD REASON AND I
SENATORS- TO VERY WELL GREEN.
GEN A TREND ECONOMIC TO THE AND
FOR OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
IT'S A FAST GROWING GLOBALLY
TRADED COMMODITY WITH LARGE
EXPORT POTENTIAL. ALREADY MANY
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD ARE
VYING TO BECOME THE LEADING
GREEN HYDROGEN PRODUCER
GLOBALLY INCLUDING AUSTRALIA
CHILE SPAIN AND EVEN SAUDI
ARABIA. I WANT US TO BE THAT
TOP PRODUCER MY FAVORITE NATION
STATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA HAS SO MANY GLOBAL
ADVANTAGES FOR THE PRODUCTION
AND EXPORT OF GREEN HYDROGEN.
INCLUDING ABUNDANT RENEWABLE
FEEDSTOCKS SKILLED WORKFORCE HI
TOWARDS EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
MANY LARGE LOCAL USES A GREEN
HYDROGEN CUT THE SELLER TAKES
GAILLAC. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
LEADERSHIP. SB EIGHTEEN IS
ESSENTIAL TO ESTABLISHING AN
APPROPRIATE VISION AND LEGAL
AND REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE ITS RIGHTFUL
PLACE IN THIS EMERGING GLOBAL
GREEN HYDROGEN ECONOMY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EITHER THANK YOU. MODERATOR CAN
YOU ALSO NOW Q. JAMIE. ELEVEN
YES SIR. SURE HUESO AND MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE THIS IS
JAMIE LEVIN I PRESUME YOU CAN
HEAR ME YES WELL I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF WEST COAST
OPERATIONS CENTER FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT I AM LOCATED IN
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA OUR FIVE OH
ONE C. THREE NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION IS COMMITTED TO
THE DEPLOYMENT. OF AND
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES SPECIFICALLY IN THE
HEAVY DUTY MARKET WE HAVE BEEN
RECIPIENTS OF FUNDS FOR FUEL
CELL TRUCKS BUSES MARINE CARGO
HANDLING EQUIPMENT. AND WE HAVE
SEEN OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND OUR OWN ENDEAVORS
WORKING WITH VARIOUS TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN FLEET OPERATORS THE
SUCCESSFUL DEPLOYMENT OF THESE
VEHICLES BASED ON THEIR
EXTENDED RANGE UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED MILES ON A SINGLE FILL.
THEIR PAYLOAD CAPACITY IN THE
ABILITY TO FUEL QUICKLY AND
THEY ARE PROVING NOW THERE IS A
CENTRAL COMPONENT. TO THE
ELECTRIFICATION OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THE
CONVERSION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. WE HAVE WE ARE ME
MEANING. TANK TO. ZERO MISSION.
BUT WE CANNOT MEET THREE WELL
TO WHEEL IT UNLESS WE PURSUE
THE- LEGISLATION THAT SENATOR
SKINNER HAS PROPOSED TO THE S.
B. HE- WE HAVE THE DEMAND
GROWING IMPROVING ITS VIABILITY
WE NEED THE FUEL SUPPLY COULD
BE GREAT TO BE MADE GREEN AND
AFFORDABLE SENATOR. SKINNER'S
BILL WILL HELP PURSUE AN
ACCELERATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IN THE QC
TO DELIVER THE GREEN HYDROGEN
THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO OUR
STREETS GOALS OF TRANSFORMING
OUR TRANSIT INDUSTRY TO GENERAL
MISSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVIN WOULD
PER SHARE COMMENTS NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE GALLERY HERE
FOR THE PUBLIC. MANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC PUBLIC HERE IN THE
GALLERY WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTEEN. NOBODY
NOW WILL GO TO ROOM. ONE
TWELVE. ANYONE AND NO THERE
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE ANYBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. NOW WILL GO
TO- WITNESSES TESTIFYING VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY OF
THAT. IS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON SB EIGHTEEN IF NOT
PLEASE KILL THE PUBLIC LET THEM
KNOW THAT OF LINES ARE OPEN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHARE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD HMI WOULD
DRY YOUR COMMENT AT ANY TIME BY
REPEATING THE ONE ZERO COMMAND.
IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
YEAH AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO SHARE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT AT THIS TIME. WELL WE
GET OF. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
UNION AND THIS I'M JUST GONNA
GO AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
OPPOSITION IF WE HAVE ANYBODY
IN THE GALLERY. ANYONE OF THE
GALLERY LIKE SPEAK OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL TO S. B. EIGHTEEN.
OR ANYBODY AND ROOM ONE TWELVE
IT DOESN'T BE APPEAR TO BE
ANYONE IN ROOM. ONE TWELVE
MODERATOR DID WE GET ANYONE.
WISHING TO SPEAK AND IN FAVOR
OF SB. EIGHTEEN AS ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. OKAY WE RECOMMEND FROM
LINE NUMBER ET THAT'S EIGHT
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. EXCUSE ME
IT LOOKS EIGHT ZERO HAS DROPPED
WHAT LOOKED. THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MEMBERS JULIE ARE
LETTING ON BEHALF OF THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SH WE ARE LISTED IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTEEN BUT- FOR
THE MOMENT OUR POSITION IS
ACTUALLY SUPPORT IF AMENDED. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOALS OF
THIS BILL AND AGREE WITH
SENATOR SKINNER AND THE SPONSOR
THAT SRI HYDROGEN IS CRITICAL
TO THE STATE'S PERMITTING
POLICIES AND CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE AND WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
SKINNER AND HER STAFF ON THE
DEFINITION OF GREEN HYDROGEN
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEFINITION
THE BILL RIGHT NOW- DOES NOT
TAKE A LIFE CYCLE BASED
APPROACH AND WE THINK THAT
THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL- FOR THE
DEFINITION GREEN HYDROGEN AND
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT ANY
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS NEED TO
BE APPLIED. TO ALL SOURCES OF
GREEN HYDROGEN EQUALLY- BUT WE
ASSUME THAT WE CAN WORK OUT
THOSE CHANGES WITH THE SENATOR
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HER AND THE COMMITTEE. ON
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
LEAVE ANY OTHER. YES WE DO
WOMAN. THE NEXT ONE IN LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS HIT ME FAN ON BEHALF OF
AN E. AT THE COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. YES LINE
NUMBERS SEVENTY NINE IN LINE IS-OPEN SEVEN NINE. GERMAN HUESO
MEMBERS THAT MIKE MONICA BE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE HI CRAIG COUNSELL. LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER FOR
HEARING OUR CONCERNS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
NEXT WAS A LITTLE YES- LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GREG COOK REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU. OKAY NEXT BICKER. MY
NUMBER IS SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SERRA GERSON FOR EARTHJUSTICE
EARTHJUSTICE IS NOT TAKEN A
POSITION ON SB EIGHTEEN
GARRETT- BUT WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TO ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS
WE HAVE SPECIFICALLY. ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF GREEN HYDROGEN
BECAUSE YOU WERE REALLY
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE HYDROGEN RESEARCH SAYS THAT
THE STILL SUPPORTS JONES-
BECAUSE ANY INCREASES IN
GREENHOUSE GASES OR LOCAL
POLLUTION AND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER IS SEVENTY
THREE A LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS TELLING
JACK ON BEHALF OF CAL START IN
SUPPORT. NEXT BIGGER. ONE
NUMBER FORTY FOUR YOU'LL AND IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS RYAN
MCCARTHY REPRESENTING TRUE
NORTH- AND THE GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION COMPANY AQUA
HEINRICHS THEY'RE THE ONLY U.
S. BASED ELECTROLYSIS COMPANY
CURRENTLY AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB EIGHTEEN AND
APPRECIATE SENATOR SKINNER'S
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP. TO
SUPPORT AND EXPAND GREEN
HYDROGEN AND ZERO CARBON ENERGY
RESOURCES PUTTING CALIFORNIA ON
THE MAP IT'S AN INTERNATIONAL
MARKET LEADER IN GREEN HYDROGEN
AND ACCELERATED TOWARD STATES
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS THANK IN
ORDER MIND THE COLORS TO STATE
YOUR NAME. THE ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. LINE
NUMBERS SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AMERICAN PARKING REQUESTING
STATE PATROL IN THE SITUATION
WE ACTUALLY CALLED ME A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THE BELL AND THEN
JUST TO CLARIFY THAT POSITION
OUR MEMBERS ARE ENGAGED I LIKE
THE PART ABOUT WE NEED TO.
THINK HIKER SOUNDS LIKE THE
AUTHORED TAKING AND TODAY. IN
THE BALCONY MARKETS AND-
GENERALLY VERY SUPPORTIVE AND-
I AND ALSO JUST LIKE TO STATE
THAT WE LOOKING FOR. NOT LONG
AND HOW. I'LL. WE WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT WOULD WORK ABOUT
INCENSE IN THE BELT. OFFICE
ABOUT PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP AND
COULD BE THE COUNTRY SIX BACK
QUICKLY HOW PROJECTS WORKING
OTHER GOVERNMENTS THAT THEY YOU
VERY. THANK YOU NECK PICKUP. MY
NUMBER IS SEVENTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY IS LUKE
HER NOT AND I WENT GOSHEN CAL
TULARE COUNTY. THE REASON I
MIGHT CALL IT A RESEARCH THE
ONE YEAR SENATE THREE FIVE. I
WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
SURROUND WHAT INVESTORS WRONG
BILL FLICK JUST. REMIND THE
COLOR AS THREE FOR FIVE LATER
IN OUR- RIGHT NOW WE LISTENING
TO S. B. IF WE CAN GET THE NEXT.
IN OF A B. EIGHT. THANK YOU.
AND I COME FROM LIVE. SIXTY
PLEASE GO. MY NAME IS DAVE
MCNARY SENIOR MANAGER OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
MITSUBISHI POWER SPEAKING. THE
LEADER IN THE DEPARTMENT BASIN
TECHNOLOGY- INCLUDING LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE STORAGE
BE A GREEN HYDROGEN POWER
PARTNER SKINNER AND CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE FOR READING ALL THE
DEVELOPMENT TO ADVANCE THE
ADOPTION OF THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE STRUCTURE ASKED ABOUT
THE EIGHTEEN AND A CLEAR MARKET
SIGNALS THE CALIFORNIA
PRIORITIZING LONG DURATION
STORAGE YOU CAN YOU CAN TAKE.
STEPS TOWARD THE DECARBONIZE
CREEK THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. ENCOURAGE
NOT A- THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
PLEASE. LIVE. FORTY FIVE. NEXT
BAKER HEREBY DECLARED THANK YOU
BYE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SORRY ARE YOU SURE
NUMBERS WE CAN ACCORDING TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
MEDITATION ON THE BILL AND
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION BECAUSE TO DATE.
THAT THE CLARIFIER POSITION
REAL QUICK GIVEN HOW INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX ISSUE IT'S FROM VIDAK
BUT I DON'T G. FORCES THE
PRODUCTION PRACTICES THAT COULD
BE USED IN HYDROGEN PRODUCTION
WE THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO BE CLEAR AND PRECISE AND
CRACKING DEFINITION THE BILL.
ON THE GOAL OF DIRECTING
AGENCIES TO EXPLORE QUESTIONS
THAT ARE NOT READILY APPARENT
RATHER THAN LOCKING IN AN
OVERLY BROAD DEFINITION OF
STATUTE THAT COULD LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SHOULD
FINALLY THINKING ABOUT FOCUSING
THE USE OF GREEN ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN ON FACTORS WHETHER FEW
OTHER DECARBONISATION
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE BUT
AGAIN. REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE TIME THE SENATOR STOPPED AT
THE SPENDING ON THE BILL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
FASHION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. SPEEDLINE SIR WHO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
JASON BARBERS OF THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS- WHERE AN
IN BETWEEN OR DO NOT HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION- YOU HAD SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DEFINITIONS
THAT BEHIND AGAIN BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE- GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT THE
CURRENT SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KAREN
MEMBERS THAT THEY LOOK AT THE-
CRANK HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER. HEADLINE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MAP BROUGHT ON THE AFTER THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL CALIFORNIA OUR
POSITION IS A TWEENER TODAY
WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF GETTING IT
MAYES FROM WILL BE SUPPORTIVE
OF EACH TEAM BETTER STILL
BETTER IN THE LATEST ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS ON OUR HANDS AND YOU
WANT TO DIDN'T THINK SANDERS
SKINNER. AFTER. WORKING SO
COLLABORATIVELY. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. THANK YOU IN MECHANISM
LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BILLS LOCAL UNEXPECTED
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL.
BUSINESS COUNCILS IN SUPPORT OF
IT SPEAKING FOR ALL THE REASONS
CITED BY BOTH WITNESSES TODAY.
WORKING PRODUCTION DISTRIBUTION
GREEN HYDROGEN WE FEEL THIS
BILL IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. OKAY
NEXT BIGGER. THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE COMMENT AND OUR FINAL
QUICK COMMENT COMES ALIVE FORTY
FIVE. FIVE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE HAVE NO- COMMENTER
THEIR PHONE IS ON MUTE. WITH NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. NO ONE ELSE AND
WILL MOVE- NOW IF YOU COULD
PLEASE- US FOR WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON. ONE PERSON. DIçN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM CARMICHAEL
WITH SEMPRA ENERGY UTILITY. ONE
MOMENT HERE. REMAINING ISSUES
RELATED TO ORGANIC WASTE AND
HYGIENE PRODUCTION VERY PRO
HYDROGEN AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU ARE
NOT CAN WE- ASK FOR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. CAN WE HAVE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR. THE MODERATOR THERE.
SB EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR THERE
IS THERE'S ONE PERSON WITH AN
OPERATOR AT THIS MOMENT. AT
NINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JAMIE
COUNCILLORSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
APPRECIATE THE OTHERS
LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN ENERGY
HOWEVER WE MUST OPPOSE SB
EIGHTEEN UNLESS IT IS AMENDED
TO NO LONGER INCLUDE A
DEFINITION OF. GREEN HYDROGEN
SOURCES THAT POLLUTE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND MAKE INCREASE
METHANE EMISSIONS WE ARE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
HYDROGEN GENERATED FROM BIOGAS.
DAIRIES BEING DEFINED AND
MARKETED AS GREEN ENERGY. HE
DIED DO ALMOST NOTHING TO
MEDIATE THE SEVERE WATER AND
AIR POLLUTION IMPACTS BUT
ESPECIALLY LARGE KERRY HOW. ON
NEARBY LOW INCOME SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY COMMUNITIES AND IN FACT
ARE MORE LIKELY TO EXACERBATE
THOSE IMPACTS BY ENCOURAGING
LARGE SCALE OPERATIONS AND
INCREASED HER EXACT SIZES. YOUR
BIO METHANE INFRASTRUCTURE
YOU'D BE HAPPY TO MEET WITH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
DISCUSS THESE CONCERNS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. FOR
WILL WILL COME TO THE-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATORS
ANYONE WISHING TO COMMENT-
CENTER DOLLY. VICE CHAIR THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIR I WILL I WANT
TO JUST THANK THE AUTHOR FIRST
OF ALL- I NEVER THOUGHT I'D
LIVE TO SEE THE DAY WHERE WE
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT A GREAT.
REALLY CLEAN ENERGY THAT'S
AVAILABLE- ALL OUT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- AND I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A BETTER TRANSITION ENERGY
THAN BATTERIES QUITE FRANKLY
HYDROGEN PUTS OUT WATER. WHEN
IT'S WHEN IT'S USED FOR FUEL
AND- WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH
ALL THE BATTERIES AFTER WE GET
DONE SO I'M SUPER EXCITED ABOUT
THIS BILL I DO HAVE A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR THOUGH- CAN YOU
COULD PLEASE CLARIFY. FOR THE
RECORD AND THAT IS WOODY
BIOMASS PART OF THIS GREEN
ENERGY- GREEN GREEN HYDROGEN I
SHOULD SAY- THROUGH THE CHAIR
THE CIRCUIT. YES OKAY THANK YOU
REALLY APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
SO IN THE ANALYSIS YOU WILL
NOTE THAT THE- THERE IS A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THESE NOTIONS
OF KERKORIAN'S MEDIA GET THE
ROOM TO BE WAS A TURQUOISE BUT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BLUE
HYDROGEN AGREE NITROGEN THESE
VARIOUS- THEY'RE NOT IN
STATUTES YET BUT- AS I
INDICATED BEFORE THE ONLY THING
WE HAVE IN STATUTES YET A FOR A
DEFINITION IS GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN SO WHAT
I'M TRYING TO DO HERE. IS
CREATING DEFINITION FOR ANY
HYDROGEN PRODUCED BY KNOWN
FOSSIL FUEL FEEDSTOCKS SO THAT
OF COURSE WOULD INCLUDE WOODY
BIOMASS NOW AS YOU HEARD FROM
SOME OF THE SCREENERS THERE
THEY HAVE A CONCERN THAT-
PERHAPS THE DEFINITION WOULD BE
WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY THAT
WOULD EXCLUDE IT THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT MY INTENTION
THOUGH- CLEARLY THERE'S STILL-
DISCUSSIONS TO BE HAD WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BUT AT THE MOMENT.
I VIEW THE WOODY BIOMASS AS A
NON FOSSIL FUEL SOURCE AND
SHOULD BE ONE OF THE FEEDSTOCKS
FOR GREEN HYDROGEN. THANK YOU
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION I'M
SUPER EXCITED TO HEAR THAT. I
JUST WANTED IT ALSO JUST FOR
THE RECORD SAY. THAT WE'VE HAD
MILLIONS OF TREES BURN OUT AND
WHEN THEY DECAY THERE PUTTING
UP NOTHING WHICH IS A POISONOUS
GAS- WE CAN USE THOSE TO CREATE
HYDROGEN WHICH IS A CLEAN FUEL
SO. I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
LEGISLATION DAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU. ON
SOMETHING THAT'S SUPER EXCITING
I THINK FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
ACTUALLY FINALLY BE MOVING
FORWARD ON AN ENERGY THAT'S
TRULY CLEAN- WHEN WE HAVE
EXCESS ELECTRICITY TO MAKE IT
SO I APPRECIATE THAT. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO- WATCHING THIS
BILL GO TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
AND GET SIGNED. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU I AM ALSO VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS IS SOMEBODY
WHO COMMUTES BACK AND FORTH
EVERY DAY GARCIA MY ELECTRIC
CHARGE- BUT I GO TO AG LAND AND
STILL SEE ALL KINDS OF- OPEN
BURNS AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
ALL KIND OF ORGANIC WASTE OUT
IN OUR FIELD AND- BEING
PRODUCED AT OUR DAIRIES AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE AND IT'S
ALREADY THERE WHEN I TOOK MY
PRODUCING NEW IT IS THERE IT
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH AND IF
WE DON'T DEAL WITH IT IN A
CLEAN WAY AND THEN WE JUST
CONTINUE TO ADD TO THE TO THE
WASTE. SO FOR ME THIS JUST HITS
ALL I MEAN CREATING MORE ENERGY
AND YOU AND WE CAN STORE IT
ANOTHER HUGE ISSUE AND WE CAN
ALSO USE WHAT'S ALREADY IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE USE- FOR
ALL OTHER PARTS OF OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR ENVIRONMENT SO I'M ALSO
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS AND
LOVE. TO BE A CO AUTHOR WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT. SENATE
HERTZBERG ONES. I DID. THINK
MISTREATMENT. I JUST WANT TO
PUT THIS DISCUSSION IN A LARGER
CONTEXT FROM. MY EXPERIENCE IN
LIFE AND YOU KNOW WE TRY IS
HUMAN BEINGS TO COME UP WITH
NEW WAYS. TO CREATE ENERGY VERY
SORTS WHEN THE AUTOMOBILE WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED FOR THE FIRST
FOURTEEN YEARS 80% OF THE CARS
WERE STEAM ENGINES. AND IT
SHIFTED TO THIS INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE FOR WHATEVER
POLITICAL OR OTHER REASONS
CERTAINLY WATER WAS A LOT
CHEAPER THAN OIL AT THE TIME.
AND WE HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH
FOR THE LAST MANY YEARS A
SERIES OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES. TO
TRY TO COME UP WITH THE
ULTIMATE PERPETUAL ENERGY IN A
BIGGER THINK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. THE MALDIVES HAVE
A RELIABLE ENERGY STANDARD
PORTS FULLY INSTEAD OF A 100%
BECAUSE THEY INTEGRATE ALL
THEIR VARIOUS TECHNOLOGIES. I
AGREE WITH- THE COMMENT MADE
EARLIER ABOUT BATTERIES. SO
MUCH OF WHAT WE DO I MEAN
BATTERIES ARE HEAVY METAL
THEY'RE GOING TO GO INTO TO
LANDFILLS THEY'VE GOT ALL SORTS
OF CONSEQUENCES FOR. EVEN SOLAR
EIGHT YEAR ENERGY PAY BACK
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO GO
WITH NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS
THERE PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS GOING
TO BELLY ACHE ABOUT. WHERE WE
ARE BUT WE ARE AS A LEGISLATURE
IS WE ALWAYS INVENTED WE CREATE
COME UP WITH NEW IDEAS. THIS IS
A FRAMEWORK LOOK AT
ELECTROLYSIS WILL FURTHER
REFINE THIS DEFINITION
EVERYBODY'S AND THINGS WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH IT I THINK IT'S
GOING TO CREATE A LOT OF JOBS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO REALLY
MOVE US TO A MUCH MORE
INTELLIGENT APPROACH. TO ENERGY
PRODUCTION AS PART OF AN
INTEGRATED PACKAGE OF
EVERYTHING WE DO THE ENERGY
CRISIS THAT WE HAD. WAS NOT
JUST A CRISIS ABOUT THE LIGHTS
GOING OUT BUT WAS A CRISIS THAT
A VERY SMALL GROUP OF COMPANIES
HAD TOTAL CONTROL OVER OUR
ENERGY PRODUCTION. AND WE HAVE
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH WHETHER
IT'S THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
POLAR. ALL SORTS OF WAYS TO
DEAL WITH HOW TO CONVERT. OUR
SOURCE OF ENERGY AND SO I THIS
IS A VERY CREATIVE AREA THE
TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING
DRAMATICALLY. AND IT IS JUST
ANOTHER STEP OF THE KIND OF
APPROACH THAT THIS COMMITTEE
NEEDS TO TAKE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE THIS GOVERNMENT
NEEDS TO TAKE. TO INVENT THE
FUTURE ASK FOR SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU THE CENTER.
BRADFORD DID YOU HAVE YOUR MAKE
UP. THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU TO THE FOR
BRINGING THE COMMENTS MEASURE
BUT- I DO HAVE CONCERNS AND IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE ROLE THAT
CAR WILL PLAY AND I THINK WE
ALL SHOULD BE CONCERNED BASED
ON THE RECENT AUTHOR. OF CARBS
IN ABILITY TO. REALLY MONITOR
ANY OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY'VE BEEN TASKED WITH THE
COME BACK WITH FEASIBLE WAYS
OF. HOW TO BEST SPEND DOLLARS
IN IT AND EVEN THE AUDIT SAYS.
THEIR THEIR PRACTICES ARE
INDEFENSIBLE AND TO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW CAR TO DETERMINE WHAT'S
BEST FOR LOW INCOME. OR
MINORITY COMMUNITIES IS TOTALLY
LAUGHABLE I ONLY WISH THERE WAS
ANOTHER AGENCY WHO WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SCOPING
PLAN. AND COMING BACK WITH
FEASIBLE PLANTS ARE REALLY
ADDRESS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE BECAUSE THEY ARE TRAINABLE
BUT CARPETS CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED. THEY'RE NOT THE
AGENCY TO BE IN CHARGE OF THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE- CENTER
CERTAIN. THANKS RICHER-
APPRECIATE THE BILL AND GETTING
OUT AHEAD OF THIS IF I THINK IS
A REALLY SMART APPROACH JUST.
GIVEN ALL THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT IN NEW ACTIVITY IN
THIS ARENA I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PUT SOME
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE- SO I THINK
THE BILL SMART IN THAT WAY- I'M
JUST HOPING THE AUTHOR CAN YOU
JUST DRILL DOWN A LITTLE BIT I
KNOW WOODY BIOMASS WAS BROUGHT
UP BUT- THE CONCERNS RAISED BY-
SOME OF THE TWEETERS. ABOUT
SORT OF THE LIKE WHAT
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS ARE
GOING TO BE AROUND THE VARIOUS
FEEDSTOCKS SO I WOULD IMAGINE
FOR INSTANCE A LIKE. WOODY
BIOMASS TAKEN OUT OF OUR
PROJECTS THAT'S NOT SUSTAINABLY
HARVESTED WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE
OR- THAT THERE'S ACT BIOMASS
FOR INSTANCE THAT WE YOU KNOW
DIDN'T COMPLY WITH THE LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS ALIKE JUST HOW TO.
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE.
EVEN ON THE DAIRY IN THE
METHANE FRIEND I KNOW THAT'S A
BIG ISSUE CAN YOU JUST TALK
THROUGH. AND HE'S TRYING TO
STAY HIGH LEVEL BUT HOW TO
NAVIGATE ALL THE SORT OF ISSUES.
THE CHAIR THEY HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED. SO YOU KNOW THESE ARE
IT'S LIKE SO MANY THINGS. DO WE
LOOK TO ONE STATUTE. TO TAKE
CARE OF ALL PROBLEMS NOT
NECESSARILY. AND CERTAINLY WHEN
IT COMES TO ITS TAKES
SUSTAINABLE FORESTRY PRACTICES.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED. OUR
EXISTING STATUTES ENFORCED. FOR
BOARD POTENTIALLY NEW TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE HARVESTING
MANAGING MAINTAINING OUR FOR
SUSTAINABLY. AND TO BURDEN OUR
DEFINITION OF GREEN HYDROGEN ON
WHETHER OR NOT THAT PRACTICE
WAS MET IT'S NOT A FAIR BURDEN.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
WHILE I APPRECIATE THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT IF WE FOR EXAMPLE
ALLOW FOR- WOODY BIOMASS
GASIFICATION THAT THERE'S OTHER
POLLUTANTS THAT COULD EMERGE.
AND YES THAT IS POTENTIAL
HOWEVER. HI TO CHEN HAS LEAGUE
REDUCE POTENTIAL FOR SOME OF
THE MOST NORTHERLY PROBLEMS WE
HAVE LONG HILLS LONG HAUL
TRUCKING. DIESEL POLLUTION IS
NOT ONLY DETRIMENTAL FROM A
CLIMATE PREVIEWS IT IS KILLING
PEOPLE IT IS KILLING
CALIFORNIANS NOW IT IS THE
SINGLE LARGEST FOREIGN SOURCE
OF SO MANY POLLUTANTS THAT ARE
CREATING ALL KINDS OF HEALTH
IMPACTS AND SO TO LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL FOR NOW I CERTAINLY
DON'T AND I MY BILL DOESN'T
ADVOCATE THAT WE CONVERT ALL
LONG HAUL TRUCKS TO HYDROGEN
THAT WAS PRODUCED USING FOSSIL
FUELS NO THAT'S NOT SMART.
HOWEVER IF WE ARE UTILIZING
BIOMASS AND WHILE I WANT TO
AVOID ANY OTHER POLLUTANTS AS A
RESULT OF IT AND I THINK WE
SHOULD NEED TO TIGHTEN UP RULES
AROUND BIOMASS AND SUCH I DO
NOT WANT TO EXCLUDE HYDROGEN
FROM BIOMASS AND I THINK SOME
OF AND I WILL CONTINUE TO TALK
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY TO GET TO A
MEETING OF THE MINDS. BUT I AM
FAR MORE INTERESTED IN CUTTING
OUT DIESEL AND I DO NOT KNOW
WHAT OTHER AND I'VE NOT YET
HEARD OR SEEN OTHER TOOLS FOR
DOING SO AND ELECTRIFICATION
CAN ONLY GO SO FAR THERE SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO BALANCE THAT
IN THE DEFINITIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SO THAT WE DON'T GET
SOME SO TIGHT THAT WE EXCLUDE
IN OUR ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE THIS
USE OF THIS RESOURCE AND A
TRANSITION NERI WAY. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER. IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A GOOD
CLOTHES. FOR YOUR LIFE GOING TO
BE MY CLOTHES SO YEAH- BUT IF I
COULD JUST ADD ON A FEW
COMMENTS OF MY OWN BECAUSE I'M
WORKING ON A- HYDROGEN BILL
THAT I THINK WILL WORK TOGETHER
WITH. A CENTER SKINNER'S
HYDROGEN BILL BUT- GENERALLY MY
BILL ALSO INCLUDES SOME
PROVISIONS THAT WILL WILL
ADDRESS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AS WELL BECAUSE OFTEN
TIMES. A MISSIONS ARE LOCATED
IN SOME OF- CALIFORNIA'S MOST
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND IF
WE CAN CAPTURE. THOSE EMISSIONS
TURN THAT INTO HYDROGEN- IN
ESPECIALLY IN SOME FORMER. OF
SUPERFUND SITES OR SOME FORMER-
YOU KNOW FOSSIL FUEL. ENERGY
PRODUCTION SITES IT WOULD BE A
GOOD TRANSITION TO- CREATE JOBS
AND ALSO CREATE RENEWABLE
NATURAL POWER. FROM THE SOURCES
SO THAT'S A BILL THAT WILL COME
TO COMMITTEE LATER AND WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO FURTHER
DISCUSS THIS. BUT WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH SENATOR
SKINNER ON THE DEFINITION TO
MAKE SURE. THAT ACHIEVES THE
GOALS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
STATE AS WELL SO. THANK YOU US
CENTER SKINNER WE HAVE A MOTION
AND JUST TO CLARIFY CENTER
SKINNER YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
I WILL I'M SORRY YES I AM A
SEVENTEEN COMMITTEES MOMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER-
CLERK- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE
HAVE A MOTION. BUDGET BASS BILL
FORWARD WITH A SUGGESTED WHAT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
EIGHTEEN BY CENTER SKINNER TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY- WESSEL BY- TURN WEST
ON. MEISTER DOLLY. INTO THE
MIKE PLEASE IN GERMAN THESE BY
PRICE FOR DOLLY EIN SENATOR
BAKER HI SENATOR BAKER HI.
SENATE BURGESS. NEXT NUMBER.
SENATOR BRADFORD. SEVEN A
BRADFORD AYE SENATOR DOT ORG
SENATOR DODD I. SENATOR EGGMAN
HI SENATOR EGGMAN I SENATOR
GONZALEZ HI SENATOR GONZALEZ I.
SENATOR GROW. SENATOR HERTZBERG
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG HI SENATE
MCGUIRE. SENATOR MEN BY SENATOR
MEN I. SENATOR RUBIO FIVE
SENATOR RUBIO I SENATOR STERN
ALL RIGHT SENATOR STERN I. WELL
THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET UP WILL HOLD LOCAL ROLE
OPEN FOR OPTIONS MEMBERS THANK
YOU CENTER SKINNER WILL MOVE UP
TO ITEM FOUR SB TOOL FOR BY
SENATOR DODD. THE RELATED TO
ELECTRICITY DEMAND RESPONSE
SENATOR DODD. THIS FEATURE
WOULD YOU PREFER ME TO BE BACK
THERE OR CAN I GO TO MY DESK
YOU CAN DO IT AT YOUR DESK.
THAT'S FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS SB
TOOL FOR CODIFIES AND
STANDARDIZES THE RULES FOR BASS
INTERRUPTIBLE PROGRAM ALSO
KNOWN AS PIPP. I ACCEPT THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS NOTED TO
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSISTHANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HER
HELP. THE FILM IS AN EMERGENCY
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAM IT
HELPS CONTRIBUTE TO THE GRID
RELIABILITY WITH GENERATION
CAPACITY BECOME SCARCE OR
DURING TRANSMISSION EVENTS
WHICH LIMITS. ACCESS TO SUPPLY.
I'M SURE EVERYONE ON THIS
COMMITTEE REMEMBERS LAST
SUMMER'S BLACKOUT. ON AUGUST
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA CALLED ON
RELIABILITY DEMAND RESPONSE
WHICH IS MOSTLY THE BILL UP FOR
A TOTAL OF FIVE CONSECUTIVE
DAYS TO HELP MANAGE THE EXTREME
HEAT. ELECTRICITY USAGE
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED
DEMAND FOR AIR CONDITIONING. AT
LEAST SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
MEGAWATTS OF LOAD WAS SHED MOST
OF THAT BY THE INDUSTRIAL COP
CUSTOMERS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE BILL. WITHOUT THE BILL OF
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR WOULD ENFORCE
TO CALL MORE ROTATING OUT AGES
WHICH WERE DESTROYED AND NEARLY
A MILLION CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
THE FED WITHOUT ELECTRICAL
POWER. THE BILL WAS CALLED
AGAIN IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY OVER THE LABOR DAY
WEEKEND. FOR AS MUCH AS THREE
CONSECUTIVE DAYS AGAIN
PREVENTING ROLLING BLACKOUTS
BERMAN DANGER IN CALIFORNIA'S
DURING ANOTHER EXTENDED HEAT
STORM. THE BEST PERFORMANCE
DURING THE AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER
EVENTS PROVES ITS IMPORTANCE OF
BENEFIT TO THE RESIDENTS OF THE
STATE. CALIFORNIANS EMERGENCY
RELIABLE THE CHAT CHALLENGES DO
NOT END OF THE SUBSIDENCE OF
SUMMER TWENTY TWENTY HEAT
STORMS EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS.
GREAT IMBALANCES AND OTHER
CHALLENGES WILL CONTINUE. CAL
WILL CONTINUE CALIFORNIA NEEDS
CLEAN EMERGENCY RELIABILITY
RESOURCES THERE'S NOTHING
CLEANER. THAN AVOIDING
CONSUMPTION. LET ME REPEAT THAT
THERE IS NOTHING CLEANER THAN
AVOIDING CONSUMPTION AT THE
CPUC THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR IN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION DEVELOP PLANS TO
AVOID A REPEAT OF LAST SUMMER'S
ENERGY SOURCE. SUPPLY SHORTFALL
IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT THE BILL BE
AVAILABLE A RELIABLE SOURCE TO
HELP ENSURE THAT THE LIGHTS
STAY ON TO THAT END S. B. TWO
OH FOUR PROTECTS PROMOTES AND
PRESERVES RHYOLITIC RELIABILITY
DEMAND RESPONSE BY ODIFYING
THE BASE INTERRUPTIBLE PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
A CPC TO ADDRESS CUSTOMER FOR
TEA TO ENSURE CONTINUED
AVAILABILITY OF DEMAND RESPONSE
LOAD SHEDDING DURING GRADING
VIRGIN SEES AND FINALLY THE
BILL WOULD CREATE A PILOT
ECONOMIC DEMAND RESPONSE
PROGRAM TO BE ADMINISTERED
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE'S TWO
LARGEST ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS. SB TWO OR FOUR IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LARGE ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WHOSE MEMBERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SHEDDING LOAD
DURING GREAT EMERGENCIES LIKE
LAST SUMMER. I BELIEVE NORA
THREE FROM- QUICK A IS ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THE.
BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN WHAT IS
THE NAME. LARA BERNARDINO SHARE
SHARE SERVING OR A WE HAVE
NORTH FROM THE- IT'S. YES I AM.
THEY ARE IF YOU EAT SHE
CONCLUSION. MR FOR THANK YOU HI
GOOD ACTORS. YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. WITH THE ABILITY YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU TO PLEASE THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON. LARA
SHERIFF I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION OR CLICK
A- AND THANK YOU CHAIR HUESO
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY. ABOUT SENATE BILL TWO OH
FOUR AND MY THANKS TO SENATOR
DODD FOR FOSTERING THIS BILL.
pNEEDED NOW ESPECIALLY AFTER
LAST SUMMER TO ENSURE THAT THE
BASE INTRACTABLE PROGRAM
CONTINUES IN THE FUTURE AS A
CRITICAL EMERGENCY RELIABILITY
DEMAND RESPONSE PROGRAMS. THAT
MEET THE GREAT NEED THE STATE
CLIMATE NEEDS AND CUSTOMERS
NEED. IT HAS WORKED CAN MEET
THE GROUP NEEDS SINCE THE EARLY
NINETEEN EIGHTIES THAT CAN
REDUCE DEMAND AND STABILIZE THE
GRID NOT JUST DURING PEAK
PERIODS ALL PERIOD. MOST
PARTICIPANTS ARE HIGH LOAD
FACTOR CUSTOMERS MEANING THEY
DO NOT HAVE WHETHER SENSITIVE
LOAD. IT IS AVAILABLE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE DAYS A YEAR ON A COLD DAY
IN FEBRUARY A MILD EVENING IN
MAY AND DURING EXTREME HEAT
WAVE. THAT STABILIZE THE GRID
DURING BLACK ONE IF THE MEMBER
AGENCIES AS WELL AS DURING
LOCAL TRANSMISSION EMERGENCIES.
STEP OFFICE OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
HELPING TO KEEP EMISSIONS
INTENSIVE TRADE EXPOSED TO
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
CUSTOMERS IN CALIFORNIA MAKING
A GOOD PROVIDING THEIR SERVICES
WITH CLEAN GREEN POWER. KEEPING
INDUSTRY HERE AVOID EMISSIONS
LEAKAGES THAT OCCUR WHEN
MANUFACTURING LEAVES OUR GREAT
STATE. BUT IT IS HARDER FOR
THESE CUSTOMERS TO STAND
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THAT'S YOU
KNOW THE COST OF POWER HERE IS
MUCH HIGHER THAN IN THE
NEIGHBORING STATE. FURTHER
HELPS REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS
WHEN IT'S CALLED BECAUSE IT
AVOIDS THE DISPATCH OF GAS
FIRED COMBUSTION TURBINES. IT
IS AN INCREDIBLY COST EFFECTIVE
THE KEY TOOL FOR CUSTOMERS FOR
THE GRID AND FOR THE STATE. I
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR OFFERING
THIS LEGISLATION. AND
RESPECTFULLY VIRGIN ISLANDS AND
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE PUBLIC FOR SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. BUT IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE GALLERY FROM THE
PUBLIC THE WITCHES WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. NOBODY HERE
CAN WE NOW GO TO THE CALL TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE- THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE-
IDENTIFY ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. TOOL
FOR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
AND WE DO HAVE A LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS IT
NEEDS BAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THEY SHOULD BE AND
THE MAIN METRIC. OKAY NEXT
SPEAKER OUR- THAT IS LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN THAT WE GET CUT
OFF THEIR USED ONLINE. HI YES-
THIS IS DISNEY FAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. NO OTHER
SPEAKERS WILL COME TO THE
COMMITTEE ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO SPEAK.
ANYONE AT ALL RAISE YOUR HAND
OR EFFECT HARD TO SEE THE MIKES
FROM HERE SO. THE HAND RACE IF
NOT CAN WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION-
CENTER BRADFORD. YES- I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR THIS
MEASURE. BUT I DO WANT TO RAISE
SOME CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO
THIS AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO SPENT
TWELVE YEARS. OF MY LIFE
WORKING FOR UTILITY I KNOW ARE
VITALLY IMPORTANT- THE SPACE IN
A ROW REPTILE PROGRAM IS AN
HONOR HAS STATED. THE BENEFITS
BUT- WE ALL MUST SUBMIT THERE'S
NO FREE LUNCH HERE. AND IT IS A
SMALL CONSUMERS WHO SUBSIDIZE
THIS PROGRAM. AND I WOULD ONLY
ASK THAT THERE IS A SUNSET THAT
THIS IS NOT ONGOING BECAUSE
AGAIN. THE SMALLER REPAIRS WIND
UP PAYING AND THERE'S LIKE I
SAY THERE'S A COST SHIFT AND
ALL THESE PROGRAMS SUCH AS THIS
AND- WE SHOULD ASK THOSE FOLKS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING THE MOST TO
CONTINUE TO SUBSIDIZE THOSE WHO
CAN. ARE AND BETTER POSITION TO
AFFORD IT BUT IT IS A NECESSARY
PROGRAM DURING- THOSE HEAVY LOW
DAIS WORD YOU PASS THOSE LARGE
CONSUMERS TO SHIP LOW BUT-
AGAIN I HAVE GREAT CONCERNS
WITH- THE SMALL CONSUMERS
CONTINUE. TO SUBSIDIZE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THIS. I YOU WE- FORGOT
TO GO TO A SPEAKER SET UP.
CHADEMA I'M ASK YOU TO KILL
ANYONE A POSITION. OF SB TOOL
FOR IN THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE. IN THE
GALLERY OR ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- LINING UP TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION BUT IF YOU COULD NOT.
ASK IF ANYONE FROM THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AGAIN
LADIES JIM IF YOU AREN'T
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE
DO HAVE A WATER. LINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE MEMBERS IT NOT
CHILDREN AND IF SOMETHING
HAPPENS TURN WE DID. NOT POSE A
LOT UNEDITED LETTER- WE HAVE
BEEN IN COMMUNICATION WITH THE
OTHER TOPIC AND AS OF RIGHT NOW
WE WILL- HELLO- AS WE CONTINUE
OUR- YUP THEY WANT TO CREATE
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF-
WORKING WITH THAT COULD OF
POLITICAL DISCUSSION. WE ALSO
DO APPRECIATE THAT PROJECTED.
AMENDMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
VERY WELL. A CENTER BRADFORD
DID I HEAR YOU MOVE THE BILL.
THE BILL. DID YOU WANT TO
CLOSER DOT. YES MISTER CHAIR
PURCELL I DID APPRECIATE THAT
THE MOTION MOST OF ALL FROM-
THE CENTER FROM GUARDINO BUT
ALSO HIS CONCERNS ABOUT LOW
INCOME RATEPAYERS IT'S
CRITICAL. THAT WE NOT. REALLY
PUT MORE BURDENS ON OUR
RATEPAYERS ANYWHERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
NECESSARY- YOUR PROGRAM AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN BY THE AMET
REQUISITE AMOUNT OF POWER AND
NOT NEED IT BUT- IT'S BETTER
TO- TO HAVE IT NOT NEEDED- ALL
THE TIME ALSO TO- OF THE
ORGANIZATION TURN. REALLY
APPRECIATE- THEIR POSITION AT
THIS POINT TIME LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM AS WE MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD AND WHAT'S
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK. VERY WELL AND
NOT JUST TO CLARIFY YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
VERY WELL WE HAVE A TO PASS AS
AMENDED. AND. BUT DO WE HAVE TO
OTHERS SPEAKERS THEIR WISH TO
SPEAK I'M GETTING- SOME
INFORMATION. THAT WE STILL HAVE
GPS- SO MAY NOT HEARD. WE HAVE
THREE PEOPLE QUEUING UP TO A
PER OPPOSITION AND A PERSON IS
LINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- CHAU MCNEIL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION- WE- ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM- THAT HAVE
YET TO TAKE UP THE POSITION ON
THIS BILL- WE CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT IT'S AN IMPORTANT TOOL. IN
MEETING OUR EMERGENCY
RELIABILITY NEEDS HOWEVER. WE
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
LANGUAGE- THAT WE BELIEVE COULD
PREVENT CCA'S FROM OFFERING A
SIMILAR PROGRAM- AND- BUT WE
HAVE TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE WITH
THE- AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS-
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WILL HAVE A
RESOLUTION ON THIS ISSUE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS. VERY WELL
NEXT PICKER. THANK YOU AND THAT
LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON LARA PAR
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH THAT
FROM THE SPONSORS TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS. WE DO SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM AND APPRECIATE THOSE
EFFORTS TO GET US TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THAT MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANKS BAKER. WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU OKAY
WE'LL GO TO CLOSING COMMENTS BY
CENTER DODGE MAKE YOUR CLOSING
COMMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL CAN VERY WELL. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED- AND
RETURN RE REFER TO- COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CHARGES TO CLARIFY
THE MOTION IS FROM WHICH
SENATOR. FROM SENATOR BRADFORD
THINKING. SB TWO OH FOUR BY
SENATOR DODD DO PASSED AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ESSEL WESSEL I
VICE HER DOLLY. BYE BYE CENTER
DOLLY PARTON WROTE SENATOR
BAKER. HI SENATOR BAKER HI.
SENATOR BARGES. SENATE BRIDGES
I CENTER BRADFORD- SENATOR
BRADFORD BY SENATOR DODD ALL
CENTER DOT I SENATOR EGGMAN HI
SENATOR EGGMAN HI SENATOR
GONZALEZ I SENATOR GONZALEZ I.
SENATOR GROW. I SENATOR GROUP I
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI SENATE MCGUIRE I.
SENATOR MAN HI SENATOR MAN I
SENATOR RUBIO ALL RIGHT SENATOR
RUBIO I. SENATOR STERN. TOM
FOUNDATION AND- THAT'S OKAY
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. CENTER
HERTZBERG DID YOU WANNA ADD
INTERESSANTER SITTING AGAIN.
YES. SEVEN HERTZBERG ON F. B.
TWO OH FOUR. CENTER HERTZBERG
AYE. THANK YOU MA'AM CLERK FOR
THAT NOW WILL MOVE ON TO SB
THREE FORTY ONE CENTER MCGUIRE
THE RELATED TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE.
OTHER AGES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- INTO THE
COMMITTEE IS WELL FIRST OF ALL
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
YOUR FANTASTIC STAFF. FOR ALL
OF THEIR ASSISTANCE OVER THESE
PAST MANY WEEKS IN ADDITION
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF ENGAGEMENT
ENGAGEMENT FROM PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
COMMUNICATION FROM CALIFORNIA'S
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS AND
I SURE YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT
THE COMMUNICATION THE
CONVERSATION WILL CONTINUE- IF
YOU WOULD ALLOW THIS BILL TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE. IT'S THIS IS
BEEN A FOCUS AREA FOR MANY OF
US SINCE THE DEVASTATING FIRES
A TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR- DOLLY AT MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBER DIED FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY ONE
PROVIDES THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE EXPLICIT
AUTHORITY TO CREATE BACKUP
POWER RULES FOR CELL TOWERS
MAINLINE OPERATIONS IN CABLE
PHONE SYSTEMS HE AND IT
MANDATES THAT THE STATE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES SHARES
INFORMATION THAT THEY ARE
ALREADY RECEIVING FROM TELECOM
COMPANIES. ON NETWORK OUTAGES
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE REASON WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT IF YOU SEE WHO
OVERSEES TELECOMS AND CREATES
POLICY FOR TELECOMS DOESN'T
HAVE THE STATUTORY ABILITY TO
SEE THIS INFORMATION. THE STATE
OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES
DOESN'T HAVE THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY. TO SHARE THE
INFORMATION. NOW THIS IS WHY
TO. DURING TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IS PRETTY TERRORIST
BAKUL AT ITS PEAK NEARLY TWO
MILLION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TWO MILLION HAVE
THEIR LAND LINE. CELL PHONE AND
CABLE SERVICE INTERRUPTED. OUR
PHONES ARE LIFELINES IT'S HOW
WE KEEP IN TOUCH WITH THE REST
OF THE WORLD. IN HOW WE RECEIVE
EMERGENCY ALERTS. YET UP UNTIL
LAST YEAR OUR CURRENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM. IT'S
NEVER BEEN MANDATED TO HAVE
BACK UP POWER. OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
IN MANY IN THIS COMMITTEE THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO MAKE SURE
OUR OUR TELECOMMUNICATION
NETWORKS. ARE MORE RESILIENT.
IN THAT WE KNOW WHEN THEY ARE
THE MOST IMPORTANTLY WHEN
THEY'RE NOT WORKING. THE CPC IS%
RECENTLY ADOPTED DECISIONS BACK
IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY AND AGAIN
IN FEBRUARY OF. THIS YEAR
ORDERING TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP.
COMPREHENSIVE RESILIENCY PLANS
TO ENSURE THAT NETWORK
FACILITIES ARE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
SERVICE TO CUSTOMERS DURING A
DISASTER POWER OUTAGE INCLUDING
PS PS EVENTS FOR SEVENTY TWO
HOURS IN FIRE THREAT AREAS. IN
ADDITION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN VIA SENATE BILL SIX
SEVENTY THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
SUBMIT AN OUTAGE NOTIFICATION.
TO THE STATE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHICH THEN PASSES IT
TO LOCAL EMERGENCY MANAGERS
WHENEVER AN OUTAGE OCCURS IN
LIMITS THE ABILITY TO MAKE NINE
ONE ONE CALLS. OR RECEIVE
EMERGENCY ALERTS. THIS CRUCIAL
INFORMATION REGARDING WHEN
THERE'S BEEN A FAILURE IN THE
NETWORK MAY ONLY BE SHARED
CURRENTLY WITH LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS. IN THAT MAKES
SENSE SO THOSE LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS KNOWS WHERE
THOSE ENERGY STAR THAT PUT THE
PUBLIC AT RISK IN WHEN THEY'RE
OCCURRING BUT AGAIN. NONE OF
THIS INFORMATION MAKES IT TO
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WHO IS THE REGULATOR
OF TELECOMS. THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES DOESN'T HAVE
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
SHARE THAT OUTAGE INFORMATION
WITH THE CPUC. WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION PC MUST RELY ON
STAFF INITIATED DATA REQUESTS
THE TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
TO LEARN ABOUT SOME FAILURES
THAT ARE YET- YES HAD ALREADY
BEEN NOTIFIED ABOUT. STILL SOME
OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THAT. A
CLAIM THAT THE STAFF REQUESTS
FROM THE PC ARE SUFFICIENT. BUT
I WANT TO BE HONEST THEY'RE NOT.
IN TAKE WEEKS WEEKS IF AT ALL
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION RECEIVES
INFORMATION FROM
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES IN
THIS BILL. IT WOULD BE
AUTOMATIC ONE SO WE S. RECEIVES
INFORMATION AND
TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGE WHICH
IS SIXTY MINUTES OF ADRS
DISCOVERY THEY CAN THEN SEND
ALONG TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY ONE WILL STRENGTHEN OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUIRING THE-
YES- TO SHARE OUT OF
INFORMATION WITH TO SEE IF YOU
SEE IT REQUIRES A PC TO REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN ACTION
TAKEN. ON VARIOUS ADDITIVES.
SECOND QUIT CLAIM I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT. I'VE HEARD FROM
SOME OF YOU DID THERE HAVE BEEN
CLAIMS THAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING
TO THROW OUT THE BRAND NEW
BACKUP POWER RULES. THAT WERE
RECENTLY ADOPTED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. THAT
COULD BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
NUMBER ONE. THIS BILL PROVIDES
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
THE EXPLICIT EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
TO CREATE BACKUP POWER RULES
FOR CELL TOWERS LAND LINE
OPERATIONS IN CABLE PHONE
SYSTEMS NUMBER TWO THE STRONG-BACKUP POWER RULES THAT EXIST
TODAY TO SEE IF YOU SEE WOULD
STAY IN PLACE. WOULD STAY IN
PLACE AND BE UNAFFECTED BY THIS
BILL. AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
FURTHER CLARIFY THIS THANKS TO
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION
WE'RE TAKING AMENDMENTS. TO BE
ABLE TO CLARIFY THAT IN AGAIN
THIS IS A FACT I WOULD BE MORE
THAN WILLING TO HELP FURTHER
CLARIFIED THIS IN FUTURE
AMENDMENTS IF THIS THERE THIS
IS STILL A CONCERN. COMING OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE. NUMBER
THREE. THIS BILL WILL ALSO HELP
THE STATE IF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY TO. EVER LITIGATE
THESE RULES AT THE CPUC
CHALLENGING THE FACT THAT THE
PC HAS THE EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
TO ENACT BACKUP POWER RULES AND
REGULATIONS. THIS BILL GIVES
THEM THE EXPLICIT EXPLICIT
AUTHORITY TO DO SO. SB THREE
FORTY ONE IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS IN
THE CPUC ARE DOING WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO TO IMPROVE THE
STATE'S NINE ONE ONE NETWORKS.
IN TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS ACCESS TO CRUCIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT OUTAGES
ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION STATE SHARES WILL
COUNTY REPRESENT HIS CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CITIES JUST TO NAME A
FEW. MISTER CHAIR WE ARE
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WITH
THIS DANCE THE FINAL HE'S FIRE
CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF COSTA
MESA. THEY WERE ALSO- HONORED
TO HAVE CHORUSES IN THE WITH US
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T THINK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHER FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
THANK YOU WILL GO FIRST TO- THE
SPEAKERS SUPPORT DANIEL. THANKS
TO FUNNEL IF HE IS ON THE PHONE.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON THAT YOU'RE
HUESO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- APPRECIATE THE TIME
TODAY MY NAME IS THE IT'S THE
FINAL- AND I SERVICE THE FIRE
CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF COSTA
MESA SAY. AND ALSO SERVICE THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
TODAY- THE DISASTERS AND POWER
SHUT OFFS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
SHOWN THAT THE EMERGENCY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS.
NEED TO BE IMPROVED BOTH
RESIDENTS AND OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS. SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY ONE WILL IMPROVE OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS BY
CREATING STRONGER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION. PROVIDERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHEN IT
COMES TO TELECOMMUNICATION
OUTAGES AND BACK UP POWER
SYSTEMS. WHAT WE LOOK TO THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN NORTH BAY
FIRESTORMS INCLUDING THE TUBBS
FIRE IN SANTA ROSA. OR THE
THOMAS FIRE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OR THE DEVASTATING
MUD AND DEBRIS DEBRIS FLOWS
THAT FOLLOWED IT MINUS ITO- IN
EARLY TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WE CAN
REFERENCE THE CAMPFIRE LEADER
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- OR THE
WALLS HE FIRED IT STARTED LATER
THAT DAY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
JUST JUST PROVIDING ALL VIVID
EXAMPLES TO DEMONSTRATE GETTING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SAFELY
EVACUATED IN THE EARLY HOURS OF
A DISASTER CLEARLY ELEVATES THE
DEFINE. THE DEFINING DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE OR DEATH. AND OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND OUR
RESIDENTS NEEDED AT OF COME TO
EXPECT AND RIGHT WE SHOULD
EXPECT THAT OUR PHONES WORK
WHEN DISASTER STRIKES. IN
ADDITION IT IS CENTER REQUIRE A
ARTICULATED DURING THE POWER
OUTAGES IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. WITH NEARLY TWO
MILLION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENCE- HAD A LOT THEIR LAND
LINE CELL PHONE THE CABLE
SERVICE INTERRUPTED- ANOTHER
NOTABLE ITEMS. KEEPING IN
PERSPECTIVE IT SMALLER ENERGY
IS OBVIOUSLY IF. OCCURRED IN
WITHIN THE COMMUNICATION SEAT
SYSTEM. BUT THE C. P. CPUC HAS
NO IDEA WHEN THEY ARE OCCURRING
THAT COMES BACK TO THE SHARING
OF INFORMATION. THE CPUC
REGULATES THE TELECOMMUNICATION
NETWORKS AND REQUIRES THEM TO
HAVE BACK UP POWER BUT IF
TELCOS REPORT OUTAGES TO THEIR
NETWORKS TO- YES THE CPUS HE IS
UNABLE TO FIND OUT OF THAT HOW
DID YOU ACTUALLY. HEARD SB
THREE FORTY ONE WILL RECTIFY
THIS AND WE'LL PROVE OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS. SB
THREE FORTY ONE REQUIRES- YES
TO SHARE COMMUNITY ISOLATION
OUTAGE INFORMATION WITH THE
CPUC AND REQUIRES THE CPUC TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
ACTION TAKEN. USING THE
COMMUNITY ISOLATION OUTAGE
INFORMATION. IN CLOSING I WANT
TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
THREE FORTY ONE. THANK YOU NOW
WILL GO TO CHORUSES A LOAF WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORY CELLS ARE
LOOKING ON BEHALF F THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. HAVING ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT NINE ONE ONE
MARRIAGES IS VITAL NOT ONLY TO
THE PUBLIC BUT ALSO LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRST RESPONDERS.
BOLSTERING OUTAGE MAP
REQUIREMENTS WILL MAKE THIS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION MORE
ACCESSIBLE. AND WILL IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY. ADDITIONALLY
ENSURING TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS APPROPRIATE
BACKUP ELECTRICAL SUPPLY. TO
ADDRESS OUTAGES IS IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE CONSUMERS CAN
COMMUNICATE. ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES OF DISASTER. AND FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE NOT IMPEDED FROM
DOING THEIR VITAL WORK. SB
THREE FORTY ONE ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY REQUIRING THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HELLO YES.
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT BACKUP
COLLECTIBLE SUPPLIES RULES
SUPPLY RULES. FOR THESE REASONS
CSSA IS PLEASED. TO SUPPORT SB
THREE FORTY ONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE TELEPHONE LINE I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE. IN THE
GALLERY OR IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
THE WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
ON THE TELEPHONE LINE MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. THE PUBLIC. I
SURE CAN THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT. AND OUR FIRST LINE
IS NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS IS
PAUL YODER- ON BEHALF OF THE
NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT BAKER. THANK
YOU AND THAT COMES ON LINE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER FROM
NIELSEN MARK'S MURDER ON BEHALF
OF MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
SB. THREE FORTY ONE. VERY WELL
NEXT BIGGER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND THAT COMES TO MIND
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SCHRICKER MISTER CARE MEMBERS
LIKE NOT TO HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
OF UTILITY OR NETWORK OR TURN
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BICKERED
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND THAT
COMES TO MIND NINETY FOUR- I
I'M SORRY YEAH NINETY FOUR. ONE
OH EIGHT NINETY ONE. NINETY ONE
PLEADED ED GOOD EVENING SURE
MEMBERS THEIR DOLPHIN HAPPILY
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE ONE ERIC
ONLINE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH HELLO THIS IS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBER
ASSOCIATION COUNTY NOW ALSO
I'VE KNOWN AS NINE ONE ONE
DISPATCHERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WILL
MOVE OVER TO SPEAKERS AND
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION SPEAKER STEVE
CARLSON. WITH CITY AREAS MISTER
CARLSON ONLINE. I AM MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
ALSO THINK MY COLLEAGUE BERNIE
OROZCO MIGHT BE IN THE GALLERY-
ONCOR'S CCPA BUT- HEY I
RESPECTFULLY. OKAY WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THAT CENTER
MCGUIRE OVER THE YEARS ON THE
ON THE LATEST LEGISLATION- WE
UNFORTUNATELY I BELIEVE THIS IS
UNNECESSARY AND DUPLICATE
DUPLICATIVE IN A AND A COUPLE
OF WAYS- SB SIX SEVENTY THAT
THE- CENTER MENTIONED WAS HIS
BILL THAT WE HAVE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY ON WE'RE WORKING NOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES- BOND
REGULATIONS. THOSE REGULATIONS
ARE NOT EVEN FINAL YET THERE'S
ANOTHER PROVISION OF THE BILL-
THAT WILL REQUIRE ANOTHER REAL
MAKING- IN TERMS REQUIRING
MASSIVE OUTAGES AND REQUIRES
EACH TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDER TO MAINTAIN THAT MAP.
THOSE ARE NOT REAL TIME MAPS
AND WE KIND OF QUESTION WHAT
THE VALUE OF THOSE- WILL BE
GOING FORWARD. ON THE ISSUE OF
THE- PROVIDING INFORMATION TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION- THE INFORMATION
THAT IS PROVIDED TO THE
CALIFORNIA. BOB HERTZBERG D.
SERVICES IS A REAL TIME
EMERGENCY RESPONSE INFORMATION
ON SITUATIONAL AWARENESS THAT
IS NOT THE ROLE OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHO ARE
ASKING ARE ARE AT OUR MEMBERS
FOR THAT INFORMATION SO UP WE
DON'T THINK THERE IS. THAT IT'S
NOT AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON. LASHLEY AS THE THAT
CENTER IN. THE PEWS HAS ALL-
ENACTED- RULES ON SEVENTY TWO
HOUR BACKUP POWER IN TIER TWO
AND TIER THREE HI THREAT FIRE
AREAS- THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
DOES NOT IS NOT LIMITED TO TIER
TWO AND TIER THREE HIGH FIRE
AREAS. AND WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THIS MIGHT YOU KNOW EXPAND
THINGS MIGHT EVEN CAUSE THEM TO
HAVE TO OPEN UP A NEW- EIGHT A
NEW PROCEEDING. WELL WE WOULD
HOPE ON THIS ISSUE THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER- TO STREAMLINE
THE- ROSS SAYS TO GET TO POWER
ON SITE THEY KNOW THE SENATOR-
HAS HEARD THAT WE'VE HAD
DIFFICULTY IN GETTING PERMITS
OR- THE VERY BACK OF POWER THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR- ON ON THE
SITE. AND TO AND TO LOOK FOR-
OTHER WAYS TO EXPAND
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WILL-
MILITATE AGAINST OUTAGES BUT
THAT FOR THOSE REASONS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE- WITH
THE SENATOR BUT THAT RIGHT NOW
WE A- BUNCH RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU BERNIE DID YOU WANT.
YES I MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BERNIE OROZCO CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION- WE TOTALLY AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING MISTER CARLSON
HAS JUST SAID. JUST FOR THE
RECORD. THE P. YOU SEE ONLY
FOUR WEEKS AGO FEBRUARY
ELEVENTH SUGGESTS ADOPTED THOSE
SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF BACKUP
POWER REQUIREMENTS FOR
COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS. SO WITHIN EIGHT
MONTHS OF THAT DECISION
FEBRUARY ELEVENTH WE HAVE TO
HAVE IN PLACE. AT EVERY NODE
THAT SERVES A CRITICAL
FACILITY. OR A CELL TOWER OR A
CRITICAL NETWORK THAT DOES NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO A WIRELESS
SERVICE. BACK UP POWER. NOW
THIS BACKUP POWER REQUIREMENTS.
AS I SAID IT MUST BE WITHIN
EIGHT MONTHS OF THAT DECISION
WERE ALREADY MONEY ONE MONTH
AND- AND THESE BACKUP POWER-
THIS IS LIKE A HUGE BACK UP
DIESEL GENERATORS SENATOR
SKINNER. MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
SHE IS NOT A BIG SUPPORTER OF
DIESEL GENERATION WELL IT JUST
AS AN EXAMPLE AROUND LAKE
COUNTY FOR MEDIACOM. MEDIACOM
WILL HAVE TO INSTALL A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY BACK UP DIESEL
GENERATORS JUST AROUND THE
COUNTY THIS IS IN A CLEARLY. SO
THIS IS A HUGE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT FOR OUR INDUSTRY SO
WITHIN EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF THIS
DECISION. EVERY CUSTOMER WITH
ANY TIER TWO AND TIER THREE
FIRE THREAT DISTRICT. MUST ALSO
HAVE BACKUP GENERATION SO. THE
BACKUP DIESEL GENERATORS WILL
BE THE FIRST QUICK RESPONSE-
BEYOND THAT WE WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO PUT A THREE LARGE
REFRIGERATOR SIZED. CABINETS
NEAR A NOTE SO LORD FORBID THAT
YOU HAVE A NOTE ON YOUR
PROPERTY ON YOUR LONG BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GONNA GET-
BECAUSE SEVEN TWO HOURS IS A
HUGE AMOUNT OF BACKUP POWER-
SO. THIS IS A VERY HUGE ISSUE
FOR US A HUGE INVESTMENT. IF
THE BILL WERE TO BE HELPFUL THE
THING THAT WE WOULD ASK FOR IS.
SOME ASSISTANCE IN GETTING
THOSE PERMITS FROM STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. SO A HUNDRED
TWENTY BACK UP DIESEL
GENERATORS AND LAKE COUNTY
AROUND CLEAR LAKE IT'S GOING TO
BE HUGE TASK- THE CABLE
INDUSTRY HAS FIFTY THOUSAND
GENERATORS STATEWIDE. SO THIS
IS A VERY LARGE NUMBER THE
LANGUAGE. IN THE BILL THAT SAYS
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A NEW
PROCEED. I GET CONFUSED ABOUT
BECAUSE THIS DECISION IS
ALREDY OUT- IF YOU WERE TO
CODIFY SOMETHING IN STATUTE. IN
MY OPINION NOT SEEN THE
LANGUAGE YOU MAY BE TYING THE
HANDS OF THE P. YOU- READ NEEDS
DID BUILDING TO HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY. BECAUSE I'M NOT
SURE. OUR EFFORTS ARE GOING TO
BE. AS SUCCESSFUL TO GET THOSE
PERMITS AND SO THE PC MAY HAVE
TO COME BACK AND RE OPEN THAT.
AND ALL THE OTHER REASONS THAT
MISTER CARLSON ALSO DESCRIBED
OUT IS MAPS- THE INFORMATION
THAT WE PROVIDE THE CALLOW YES
IS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE- AND
PROTECTED BY HOMELAND SECURITY.
NGUYEN SB SIX SEVENTY WENT
THROUGH IN TWENTY NINETEEN
BECAME OPERATIVE IN TWENTY
TWENTY. IT SAYS IN STATURE THAT
THAT INFORMAION IS
CONFIDENTIAL THEN TO TURN
AROUND AND TO SHARE IT WITH THE
P. YOU SEE. IT'S TO GROUNDWORK
FOR THEIR PURPOSES THE PC AND
THE RECENT DECISION. HAS SAID
THAT THEY WANT FROM
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO RESOURCES- THE
RESOURCE PLAN FOR THE
RESILIENCY SO WE WILL HAVE TO
GIVEN THE DETAIL THAT THAT NEED
TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ATTITUDES. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS FOR YOUR OPPOSE BUT IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO DO SOMETHING
TO HELP US. IN THIS ENDEAVOR WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE. EASIER
ACCESS TO- LOCAL CITING PERMITS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. OF SP.
THREE FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
AGAIN THOSE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
OUR FIRST PERSON IS LINE NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. LATE SO
ALL WE HAVE A FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DIALOGUE WITH THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER IN A
POSITION. THANK YOU AND THAT
COMES FROM A LINE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE IN MEMBERS- THIS IS YOUR
LONG DEPEND SAID REPRESENTING
CAL CALM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION ALSO
IN OPPOSITION- BUT LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORED BY OFFICE AND HIS
STAFF THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK OR IN A POSITION. THANK
YOU AND THAT'S LINE SIXTY SEVEN.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE YOUNG WOMEN ON
BEHALF OF CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION.
THIS MODERATOR OTHER ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. WELCOME TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANYONE- CENTER BRADFORD.
FOLLOWED BY CENTER GROVE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ONCE AGAIN I
STAND WHAT CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MEASURE- IT'S
NO ARGUMENT THAT. THIS IS US A
CLEARLY ARTICULATED WE NEED TO
BE IN COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
COMMUNICATION WORLD AND SO WE
LIVE AND DIE BY OUR ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE BUT- ONCE AGAIN
WE'RE ASKING CUSTOMERS WHO DO
NOT LIVE IN TIER ONE TIER TWO
OR TIER THREE. THE BEAR THE
COST OF THIS BACK UP GENERATION
WHICH AGAIN IS TOTALLY UNFAIR
TO BE THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
BEING DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY-
THESE PSP POWER INTERRUPTIONS-
NO ONE IN L. A. COUNTY WELL I
SHOULD SAY NO ONE AND ONLY
CALLING BUT THE MAJORITY OF THE
URBAN AREAS IN L. A. COUNTY OR
ANY OF THE URBAN. COMMUNITIES
OR WILL BE DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY
THESE WILDFIRES SO TO ASK THEM
TO BEAR THE COST OF BACKUP
GENERATION IS TOTALLY UNFAIR
AGAIN AS INDIVIDUAL WHO SPENT A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND THE
TELEPHONY SPACE. THE REAL ISSUE
WHEN I HEAR LAN LINES WHICH ARE
BEING INCLUDED IN THIS IT'S
ALMOST LAUGHABLE BECAUSE THE
REAL ISSUE WITH LANDLINES ARE
VERY RARELY DO GLAM LIGHTS GO
OUT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF POWER.
THEY GO OUT BECAUSE OF POOR
MAINTAIN MAINTENANCE AND.
MAINTAINING THE COPPER WATER.
JUST TEN YEARS WHEN I SERVICE
HERE UTILITY. ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE WE HAD A MASSIVE
RAINSTORMS. AND L. A. COUNTY.
IN DURING THEIR RATING STORM.
ALMOST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS. LOST ELEVEN HE HAD
NOTHING TO DO OF WILDFIRES HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH POWER
SHORTAGES HE HAD TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
WASN'T MAINTAINED. AND THE C.
LACKS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LIKE FRONTIER WERE.
UNABLE TO PROVIDE WILL FRONTIER
IS NOT A PART OF THAT. PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THEIR CUSTOMER AND
AGAIN IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
POWER OUTAGES SO THE CONTINUE
TO ADD LAN LINES AS TO. PART OF
THIS REASON FOR BACK UP POWER
IS DISINGENUOUS AN ARGUMENT IN
AND OF ITSELF- SO. I WOULD
ASKED AGAIN THAT WE ASK THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY FAR OUTAGES. I MEAN
BY FIRES IN IN EXPERIENCE A
POWER OUTAGE JUST THE BEAR THE
COST OF THIS. THAT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR. THIRD OF THAT COST
PROBABLY 25% OF THAT COST WOULD
BE A BETTER INVESTMENT TO
IMPROVE THE COPPER WIRE.
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND YOU
WOULD HAVE A BETTER- SERVICE
RELIABILITY FOR THOSE LANDLINE
CUSTOMERS. THANK YOU DO CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR IF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
SURE THIS YOUR PREVIOUS
QUESTION AND YOU RECENTLY
PASSED A BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN S. B. SIX SEVENTY IN
THE C. P. C. THE CQC RECENTLY
ADDRESSED A BACKUP POWER
REGULATIONS FOR COMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS GIVEN THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY TAKEN SIGNIFICANT STEPS
TO REQUIRE DEPLOYMENT OF BACK
UP GENERATORS AND BACKUP POWER
FOR CAN YOU- COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS CAN YOU PLEASE EXPAND
ON WHY THIS LEGISLATION IS
NECESSARY- AND I ONLY ASK THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T- I DON'T THINK
THAT WITH THE CPUC WAS REQUIRED
TO DO IN YOUR PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION. HAS BEEN ABLE TO
BE FULLY IMPLEMENTED OR
EVALUATED SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHY THE ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
A COUPLE CLARIFICATIONS NUMBER
ONE- WE HAD A BILL LAST YEAR
THAT WOULD REQUIRE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR BACKUP. IT WAS KILLED IN
THE ASSEMBLY. SO I JUST WANNA
BE VERY CLEAR THAT WE ADVANCE
THE BILL IN SO WHERE THESE
RULES AND REGULATIONS ARE
COMING FROM WHETHER THEY ARE
LAND LINE OR THEIR CELL PHONE.
FOR COMING FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. JULY WHAT
IS THE CELL PHONE. REGULATION
OF THE SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
FEBRUARY THE PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION IS NOW REQUIRING
SEVEN TWO HOUR BACKUP FOR
LANDLINE. NOW THE REASON WHY
THEY'RE DOING THAT NUMBER ONE.
LOT OF THE TRADITIONAL IF YOU
WILL TELECOMS ARE GOING FROM
COPPER TO FIBRE WHICH THEN
REQUIRES POWER BACK UP. IN WHAT
WE ALSO SIGNED TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WAS PLAN LINE EVEN THE
TRADITIONAL LOST POWER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS YEAH THAT WAS A
SUSTAIN AN OUTAGE- BASED OFF OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS.
SO UNDER SIX SEVENTY THAT
INFORMATION GOES TO THE STATE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THE STATE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES DOESN'T HAVE THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO SHARE%
THE INFORMATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. OF ANY PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WHO IS THE
REGULATOR FOR TELECOM DOESN'T
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE
TO I REQUEST THAT INFORMATION
SAID THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO. NOW THE OTHER PC'S
WHEN IT COMES TO PASS WHEN IT
COMES TO OUTAGES FOR
ESPECIALLY. OUT FIBER IN CELL
IT COULD HAPPEN IN MANY WAYS SO
LIVE IN A VERY RURAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA. FIVE YEARS AGO. A
SEMI TRUCK. TOOK DOWN A FEW
OVERHEAD FIBER WIRE. THAT
KNOCKED DOWN ALL
TELECOMMUNICATION FROM WILLITS.
ALL THE WAY UP THROUGH ARCADA
FOR FORTY EIGHT HOURS YOU CAN
GET MONEY OUT OF THE BANK YOU
CAN SWIPE YOUR CARD AT SAFEWAY.
EXCEPT FOR SO THIS ISN'T JUST
ABOUT POWER BUT THIS IS WHEN IT
COMES TO ANY OTHER TYPE OF
NATURAL DISASTER IN THESE
OUTRAGE MOUNTS ARE CRITICAL IF
YOU LIVE IN THE SERVICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDISON TERRITORY YOU
LIVE IN P. JEANNIE. YOU EXPECT
THEM TO HAVE A REAL TIME OUTAGE
MAPS AND THIS WOULD HELP THE
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION AS
WELL AS TELECOM. TO PASS TO BE
ABLE TO THESE OUTAGE MAPS IS
WELL. THE OTHER PIECE THAT I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SAY. IS THAT.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE TOOK
TODAY. NEXT TO THE CHAIR AND
HIS INCREDIBLE STAFF CLARIFY
THAT WE'RE NOT SEEKING ANY NEW
PROCEEDINGS. BECAUSE THAT'S THE
LAST THING THAT WE WANT TO DO
SO THE AMENDMENTS ARE IN THE
BILL ALL RIGHT TO SAY THAT WE
ARE NOT REQUESTING ANY NEW
PROCEEDINGS I AM HERE TODAY TO
TELL EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
IF YOU NEED US TO BE ABLE TO
CLARIFY THAT AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE COMMITTEE FOR EXAMPLE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION I'D BE
HAPPY TO DO SO BECAUSE THAT IS
NOT OUR INTENT ABOUT AND I'M
HERE TO STATE ON THE RECORD
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL MAINTENANCE WE THINK
BUT- THE CHAIR IS DON.
CLARIFIES THAT BUT HAPPY SO THE
LAST PIECE OF CITIES IS ON
CONFIDENTIALITY. UNDER PUBLIC
UTILITIES RULE FIVE EIGHTY
THREE. HI ANY INFORMATION THAT
IS SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. IS NOT P.
ARE ABLE EIGHT ISN'T SUBJECT TO
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT IT'S
CONFIDENTIAL. SO I KNOW THAT
SOME MAY SAY THAT THERE MAY BE
AN ABILITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO BE
A TO SEE THIS INFORMATION IT'S
NOT YOU CAN'T ESTIMATE OF
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST IT'S
ALREADY IN STATUTE. BUT IN THE
BILL ONLY BE HAPPY TO CLARIFY
THAT FURTHER AS WELL THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY IS I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU MISTER CARLSON.
MISTER CARLSON HAS LITERALLY
FOR THE PAST YEAR AT FROM CTIA
BEEN ON A CALL MISS REQUIRE
OKAY JUST MAKE THOSE COMMENTS I
SUPPOSE THE STATEMENTS MEASURES
FOR THE I JUST WANTED TO ASK
FOR- I JUST. FEDERAL AGENTS
QUESTIONS DID YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS SENATE OVER
ELABORATE ANSWER ON THOSE
QUESTIONS AND OTHERS I JUST
HAVE ONE MORE THAN DO YOU HAVE
A CONCERN AT ALL THAT
EXPANDING- FOLLOWING UP ON MY A
QUESTION FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM- DENIED DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION OR DO YOU HAVE A
CONCERN AT ALL. THAT YOU KNOW
REQUIRING THIS STATE WIDE
VERSUS JUST IN TIER ONE TWO AND
THREE AT HIGH FIRED THREAT
DISTRICTS THAT THAT MIGHT TAKE
AWAY FROM THESE HIGH MOST HIGH
RISK. AREAS THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
STATE. I AM THOSE. OVER ALL WE
CAN. OUR BILL WAS MY MORE. AT
RISK. IN STRATEGIC LAST YEAR IN
REGARDS TO- WHAT WOULD BE IN-
THE OUTAGE MAPS BUT I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR. THIS BILL WE
AREN'T SEEKING THEM. TO GO
BEYOND TIER ONE THAT'S IT. THE
ONLY LOOKING- IT NOT TO GO
BEYOND TIER ONE. CENTER GROVE
DID YOU HAVE ANY OTHER NO MAKE
YOU MISTER TERRY APPRECIATE
KEPT THANK ASK QUESTIONS WILL
GO TO CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY- AS IT PERTAINS TO-
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED EMPIRE
YEARS BUT I JUST HAVE A MEDICAL
A CONCERN BUT RATHER IF THE
AUTHOR WOULD ADDRESS IT- THE
PREVIOUS- I THINK HE WAS
OPPOSING NOT. STATED SOME
CONCERNS AS IT PERTAINS TO
PERMITS FROM LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES AND YOU KNOW
COMING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AYE. I KNOW THEY'LL BE SOME
CHALLENGES- HAVE THERE BEEN
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW WE CAN HELP
LOCAL. MUNICIPALITIES EXPEDITE
PERMITS OR OR PERHAPS FIND
CREATIVE WAYS TO HELP. IN THAT
REGARD. SO THROUGH THE CHAIR-
CENTER RUBIO IS A CO CHAIR OF
THE WILDFIRE WORKING GROUP.
THERE WAS A BILL THAT THE STATE
ADVANCED- AND I WOULD BE MORE
THAN WILLING TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO
HELP EXPEDITE. THOSE GENERATORS
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL- I DO
THIS IS A SENATOR DODD ALSO
PART OF IT I THINK THAT THERE
WOULD BE I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
FOR THE GROUP BUT I THINK
MAJORITY MEMBERS WOULD HAVE. A
CONSENSUS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
HAD A VERY SIMILAR BILL LAST
YEAR ON THAT I BELIEVE IT WAS
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE. THAT
WOULD EXPEDITE THOSE- THE
GENERATORS THAT WE BE MORE THAN
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY ON ACTS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. PRETTY APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. WE HAVE A MOTION ON SPILL
THE MOTION WOULD BE TO. PASS
THIS BILL. AND ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY. MCNICHOLAS SENATE
MCGUIRE MENTIONED HE IS TAKING
THE- AMENDMENTS JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY YOUR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS LOWS IN THE
COMMITTEE CENTER MCGUIRE. YES
SIR YES SO THE MOTION BE
PASSENGER PASSES AMENDED. AND
REFERRED CHU COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNOR GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. BUT DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THAT WE HAVE MOTION
BY CENTER DOT- DID YOU WANT TO
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS NOW
IS TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
DELIBERATION YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT WERE GONNA
CONTINUE WORK THROUGH YOU KNOW
MY STYLE THAT I WANT TO TRY TO
GET. AS MUCH RESULT IS
POSSIBLE- BEFORE ANYTHING HITS
THE FLOOR IN THE NUMBER TWO I
DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
MISTER CARLSON HE'S BEEN
ABSOLUTELY AT THE TABLE THE
ENTIRE TIME- AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS. WITH INDUSTRY AS
WELL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR
MCGUIRE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS AREA PUBLIC
POLICY BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU- THAT ADVANCE GET
SOME IMPROVEMENTS IN THIS AREA
THAT ARE NEEDED IN OUR STATE
SO. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN THE SILENT
CONVERSATION. WE'RE HAVING-
CLECKLEY CALL THE ROLL ON THE
MOTION. SB THREE FOUR ONE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE DO PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST THE MAN TO
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION- WESSEL BY- WESEL.
MEISTER DOLLY. MISTER DALI HI
SENATOR BAKER I. BAKER I SENATE
BRIDGES. SENATOR BRADFORD HI
SENATOR BRADFORD HI SENATOR
DODD HI SENATOR DODD HI.
SENATOR EGGMAN HI CENTER EGGMAN
I SENATOR GONZALEZ I SENATOR
GONZALEZ I. SENATOR GIRL HI THE
GIRL I SENATOR HERTZBERG BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG BY. SENATE
MCGUIRE HI SENATE MCGUIRE I
SENATOR MAN HI SENATOR MAN I.
SENATOR RUBIO HI SENATOR RUBIO
I SENATOR STERN. THE BILL IS
OUT WILL- KEEP THE ROLE PERHAPS
OF MEMBERS AND WE'LL MOVE ON
NOW TO ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B.
3405% OR BAKER THE BILL RELATED
TO ENERGY PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS
ON NON HEAVY NON ENERGY
BENEFITS. SIR BECKER WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY WHO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. SB THREE
FORTY FIVE WILL DRIVE MORE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND SHOULD BE
DID ENERGY INVESTMENTS THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THE
MOST NEED. FOR THE STARKLY BEEN
LEFT OUT. EVERY YEAR THE CPUC
OVERSEES SPENDING CLOSE TO
BILLION DOLLARS FROM PUBLIC
PURPOSE CHARGES ON UTILITY
BILLS. PROVIDING PROGRAMS TO
PROMOTE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
SHOULD BE SOLAR ENERGY STORAGE
ETCETERA. BUT IT CONSISTENTLY
SHOWS THAT LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
LAGGING BEHIND IN ADOPTING
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
DECIDING WHICH PROJECTS TO FUND
THE CBC USUALLY USES A COST
EFFECTIVENESS TEST THE
CONSIDERS ONLY THE BENEFITS OF
THE GRID SUCH AS AVOIDING THE
NEED TO BUILD MORE TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY. THESE YOU DO NOT
CONSIDER NON ENERGY BENEFITS
LIKE LOWER BILLS ARE PROVED AIR
QUALITY. WHICH DIRECTLY IMPACTS
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
PARTICIPANTS IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
WE SOULD BE AUTHORIZING THE
USE OF THESE PUBLIC PERCIFORMES
TO MAXIMIZE THE TOTAL BENEFITS.
ESPECIALLY IN TO HELP
COMMUNITIES WITH THE LEAST
ABILITY TO MAKE THE TRANSITION
TO CLEANER ENERGY. ON THEIR OWN.
THE BILL CAME DIRECTLY FROM
RECOMMENDATIONS SB THREE FIFTY
REPORT REDUCING BARRIERS TO LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
ACCESSING. THE DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES. I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAS A STRONG PITCH FOR THE
ANALYSIS I THINK THAT YOUR
OTHER STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK
ON THIS PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING HERE DOES NOT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT RATES. DOES
NOT INADVERTENTLY TIE THE PUC'S
HANDS TRIMMING THE BENEFITS. OF
COST EFFECTIVENESS AND SHOULD
BE GENERATION GOING FORWARD. AB
THESE MOMENTS MAKE THE STRONGER
AND BETTER ALIGNED ON ENERGY
BENEFITS WITH THE BILL'S
ORIGINAL INTENT. ESPECIALLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE BY TO ASSIST
ANY BY THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. WE'LL GO TO
WITNESSES NOW WE HAVE A MATCH
THEY KNOW THE GREEN LINE IN
INSTITUTE IF THAT- THE FIRM.
HELLO YES. GOD SPEAKS WONDERFUL.
GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTRACT THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER FOR OFFERING SB THREE
FORTY FIVE AND CHAMPIONING
ENERGY JUSTICE MY NAME IS MATT
CANO AND I AM THE ENERGY EQUITY
SENIOR LEGAL COUNSEL WITH THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE OF
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
NONPROFIT IN OAKLAND ARMS OF
THIS LEGISLATION I'M HERE TO
URGE YOUR SUPPORT SB THIRTY
THREE POINT FIVE I HEARD YOUR
SUPPORT TO THE FOLLOWING THREE
REASONS ONE SB THREE FORTY FIVE
HEALTH INSURER THE VALUE AND
SERVE THE INTERESTS OF LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM THE
STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY INVESTMENT
AND PROGRAMS TO SB THREE FORTY
FIVE IS CONSISTENT WITH BOTH
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ACTION PLA AND THE
ENERGY COMMISSION SB THREE
FIFTY LOW INCOME BARRIER STUDY
RECOMMENDATION THIRD AND
FINALLY SB THREE FORTY FIVE
SUPPORT ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCY WITHIN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION EXISTING
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAM FOR THOSE
REASONS I BELIEVE SB THREE
FORTY FIVE IT'S A CRITICAL STEP
TOWARD AN EQUITABLE ENERGY
TRANSITION IN CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
AND AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT MAY
ARISE THANK YOU ALL. FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION. WE ALSO
HAVE A BEGIN SALIE'S- THE CELL
HELP ENTERPRISE. MISSILE ON
FOR. HELLO. WHERE YOU. GOOD
EVENING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ABIGAIL
POLICE AND I AM THE MANAGER OF
THE FAVORABLE ENERGY SOLUTIONS
THAT HELP ENTERPRISES WE ARE A
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATION LOCATED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY FIVE.
I HAVE WORKED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FOR MY ENTIRE
CAREER AND I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN ONE I'VE FIRSTHAND
THAT FOR FAR TOO LONG OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT AND OVERLOOKED BY
BOTH THE TPC AND THE THING YOU
SEE PEOPLE MOBILE COMMUNITIES
HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE
AFFORDABLE AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
INVESTMENTS BAKER BURKE.
FAMILIES ARE DEALING WITH THE
REAL LIFE CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NOT HAD AN EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ENERGY COST SAVINGS PROGRAM
MANY LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE
FORCED TO USE COCAINE WHICH IS
VERY EXPENIVE OTHERS ARE
DEALING WITH HIGH ELECTRIC BILL
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO
UPGRADE THEIR APPLIANCES OR.
MAKE THEIR HOME MORE ENERGY
EFFICIENT. HE FAMILIES AVOID
USING. BECAUSE THEY CANNOT TO
RUN HEATER WHICH MEANS CHILDREN
GO TO BED COLD NIGHT AND ALL.
END UP GETTING SICK AND MISSING
SCHOOL. OFTEN ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOODS RELY ON BURNING
WOOD TO KEEP WARM DURING THE
WINTER ADDING TO AIR POLLUTION
AND MAKING IT HARD TO BREATHE
FOR BOTH CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
AZIMUTHALLY AND OTHER
RESPIRATORY DISEASES ARE
PREVALENT IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
EMILY IS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE STRUGGLING THE
MOST YES THEY HAVE LITTLE TO NO
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM THAT
WOULD MAKE CLEAN ENERGY MORE
AFFORDABLE. SB THREE FORTY FIVE
WILSHIRE THAT SITUATIONS LIKE%
THE ONES THAT I MENTIONED AND
OTHERS ARE NO LONGER IGNORED IT
WILL ENSURE THAT THESE
POTENTIALLY LIFE CHANGING NON
ENERGY BENEFITS ARE CONSIDERED
WHEN DETERMINING WHO HAS ACCESS
TO ENERGY PROGRAMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS I'M SB THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMMENTS WE HAVE NOBODY
HERE IN THE GALLERY WISHES
BECAUSE SUPPORT NOR. IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
THE TELEPHONE LINES MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. ANY SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FORTY
FIVE. HEY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
BR IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND OUR FIRST PERSON
IS LINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM
JONES STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
FOR THE VERSION OF THE BILL OUT
THE INTRODUCED AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE BILL
AS AMENDED AND CONTINUING. TO
WORK WITH THE OFFICE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOUR NEXT SPEAKER.
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU AN
ACT THANK YOU AND THAT COMES TO
MIND NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU YOUR NUMBER
THANK YOU TO CRY OUT FOR
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CONTRACTOR OR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL AND WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BICKERED SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND THAT COMES BEHIND AT
ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF AT THREE FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND THAT
COMES TO MIND SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS-
CAL CLARA AND SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF COURAGE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT. AND THAT IS
LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ERIN
RODRIGUEZ TO THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS ALSO
CALLING IN FOR SUPPORT-
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. VERY WELL
NEXT BICKERED SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION HI-
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY OR IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SO WILL GO DIRECTLY TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES FOR ANY
SPEAKERS. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FORTY FIVE MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL. AND OUR FIRST
PERSON AS LINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LEE AT THE REPORT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. WE ARE ALONG WITH A
GROUP OF ENERGY CONSUMERS
OPPOSED UNFORTUNATELY TO THE
MEASURE AT INTRODUCED ALTHOUGH
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS. TO CLEAR. AND
APPLICATION OF NON ENERGY THAT.
LOOK FOR A TO REVIEWING THE
CANADIAN MOBILE CAUSED THE.
REACH AGREEMENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OF SPEAKERS AN
OFFICER OF SB. THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK THANK YOU IN THAT
COME THE NEXT ONE IS FROM LINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING SIR WOULD BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THE COLOR WALKING IN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF Q. THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
MY APOLOGIES MEANT TO GET IN IN
THE END OF SUPPORT WE ARE IN
OUR TWEENER WE DROPPED IN
OPPOSITION LETTER BUT WE ARE
REMOVING THAT DUE TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTED. AND WE ARE NOW
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL I JUST
WANTED THAT USED INDICATED ON
THE RECORD DATE IN COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELPFUL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND THAT'S LINE
SEVENTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS LEAH BARRETT ON BEHALF
OF THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT WE THANK AND
AFTER THEY CAN LETTER FOR THE
BALLOT THAT WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT BE COMPOSED AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU GO A LONG WAY AND
DRAFTING. EARNS SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TOPIC AND AFFORD TO
GETTING TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
FULLY REMOVE OUR THINKING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR NEXT SPEAKER IN A POSITION
OF SB THREE FORTY FIVE. AND
THAT'S LINE NINETY NINE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THE WESTERN CAPE
THE TROLL INFESTATION AND I
WILL KEEP HER WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM MY EP AND THE
CHAMBER ON LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS. ARE
CLARIFYING THE DELL AND THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
LOOK TOWARDS FINDING A BALANCE
HERE BETWEEN OUR HIP HOP WILL
BURY AND- AFFECT THE BILL IN
THE TOURNEY AND YOU KNOW THAT
THE IMPACT OF THESE. ENERGY
FIRST INSTINCT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU PER SHARE
COMMENTS NEXT NUMBERS. LINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS YELLING
GATHERED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS THAT WE
ARE ALSO PART OF THAT LARGER
COALITION IN OPPOSITION AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENT
LANGUAGE AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT TO CLARIFY- AND SO
WE WILL. BE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE FROM LINE
ONE OH TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON JAN
MEMBER THIS IS THE GOING AT
NINE THIS WITHIN YOUR GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY I'LL GO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BUT CONCLUDES
OUR SPEAKERS ARE FROM THE
PUBLIC WILL COME TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NOW. ANYONE
WISHING TO COMMENT- CENTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AGAIN I HAVE TO RISE IN JUST
STATE MY CONCERNS AS IT RELATES
TO WHAT SOUNDS TO BE
COMMONSENSE POLICY BUT VERY
RARELY DOES IT REALLY ADDRESS
THE ISSUES AND INTENT TO
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT LOW INCOME
FOLKS- ONE SOLAR IS FAR FROM
THE TRUTH BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
CAN'T AFFORD. AND WIND SOLAR IS
OFFERED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
IT'S NOT TO SELL IT IT'S TO
LEASE IT TO THEM OR THEY DON'T
BENEFIT FROM THE TAX CREDITS
AREN'T ANY OF THE REBATE WHAT
FOLKS WANT IS AFFORDABLE
ACTRESSES THE TURN WHEN THEY
TURN ON THEIR WORKS AND THEY
CAN AFFORD IT THEY WANT
RELIABILITY. AND YOU KNOW THE
AND THAT'S THE CRUX OF WHAT
EVERYBODY WANTS YEAR TO BUT TO
CONTINUE TO SAY BUT BEFORE YOU
CAN STILL I INDIVIDUAL A SOLAR
SYSTEM WHETHER THEY'RE LOW
INCOME OR HIGH INCOME YOU GOT
TO FIRST THROUGH THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY SITUATION AND I'VE
TALKED TO TOO MANY FOLKS WHO
HAD SOLAR COMPANIES COME TO
THEIR HOUSE WITHOUT FIRST
TALKING ABOUT WHETHER IS ASIAN
YOU HAVE TO SEAL THE UNIT
BEFORE YOU CAN SIZE- A SOLAR
SYSTEM. AND FAR TOO OFTEN THAT
IS NOT HAPPENING IN IN THE
PRESENTATION ADMITTED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY BACK TO BE NUMBER
ONE ENERGY EFFICIENCY FOR LOW
INCOME FOLKS MAKING SURE THAT
THE PLACE THAT THEY LIVE IN IS-
SEALED PROPERLY SO THERE'S NO
HEAT LOSS OR NO COOLEY LOSS-
WHEN THEY'RE RUNNING THEIR
UTILITIES AND- MANY OF THESE SO
CALLED LOW INCOME FOLKS DON'T
OWN THEIR HOME SO THEY'RE NOT
IN POSITION ANYWAY TO PUT SOLAR
ON THEIR HOMES SO I JUST WISH.
POOR FOLKS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WERE NOT SYNONYMOUS ARE QUICK
BEING USED AS A POSTER CHILD
FOR WHY MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE NEEDED WHEN THEY RARELY I
SEE THE BENEFIT OF ANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND AGAIN I WILL- LEAN
BACK ON THE CAR BOUGHT IT THEY
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES THAT ALL
THE DAILY ALLOCATED FOR AS FAR
AS ENERGY EFFICIENCY ON WALL
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND GREENHOUSE
REDUCTIONS- I HAVE. VERY
RARELY- EVER. HE MET THE GOAL
AND IT THAT THEY CLAIM TO. THEY
CAN'T DOCTOR AND WE CONTINUE
AGAIN TO SAY- IT'S BENEFITING
POOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN A
VERY VERY. REACHES THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO I'LL STAND ON
THAT. THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
OF ANYONE ELSE- CENTER DOT.
YEAH I HAVE TO AGREE WITH THAT
CENTER BRADFORD AUDIO ON THIS A
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPPOSITION- AND THE POTENTIAL
COSTS TO- INCREASES TO
RATEPAYERS- THAT SAID I BELIEVE
THAT THE- AUTHOR- THIS FIRST.
YEAR BUILDING FOR THIS
COMMITTEE IS- REALLY SHOWN A
GREAT PROPENSITY TO- AT THE TOP
TO THE- TALK TO THE- THE
OPPONENTS. AND I'VE SEE THAT
THEIR- WILLING TO GIVE HIM A
SHOT LOOK AT THOSE MEMBERS SO I
WILL SUPPORT THIS TODAY BUT
RESERVE THE RIGHT. TO OPPOSE ON
THE FLOOR IF NECESSARY AND
THOSE MEMBERS- ARE NOT-
SATISFACTORY SO I APPRECIATE
THE OFFERS COOPERATION ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD AND YES WE HAVE
WORKED WITH THE AUTHOR THE
AUTHOR IS BEEN REALLY REALLY
GOOD TO WORK WITH. ON ON A-
ADDRESSING SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS AND I THINK PARTIALLY
AMENDMENTS WOULD DO THAT SO I
THINK. THEY'LL BE A DIFFERENT
STATE OF AFFAIRS IN THE NEXT
HEARING. AND OF COURSE THIS. A
BILL. BOB WOULD BE REFERRED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHERE WOULD
HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
ANOTHER HEARING THE WILL GO TO
A CENTER BAKER MY CLOSING
COMMENTS THERE'S NO OTHER ALL
WE HAVE CENTER RUBIO. ATTENTION
THAT CENTER BOARD JUST. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I ALSO WANT
TO JUST EXPRESS THAT- I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT CAME. AT THE
LAST MINUTE BUT I DID HAVE
CONCERNS AND- WE'RE GONNA. GET
THE UP TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
THAT I THINK EVERYONE
EXPRESSED. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
ALIGN MYSELF A LITTLE MORE WITH
THE CENTER FROM GARDENA TODAY
AND THAT. YOU KNOW MINORITY
GROUPS AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES
ARE USUALLY USED AS A PERTAINS
TO. THE BENEFITS BUT- I ALSO
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THESE ARE
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HARDLY
EVER SEE SOME OF THESE BENEFITS
SO. I WANT TO START THINKING IN
A IN A MUCH BROADER WAY HOW WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT IT. DOES GET
TO THESE COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO FOR JUST COMMON
YOU KNOW ALL OF US COULD NOT GO
THROUGH OUR DISTRICT OFFICES TO
MAKE THESE PROGRAMS ELIGIBLE TO
THE LOWEST INCOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THERE'S A WEATHER
IS ATION PROGRAM THAT'S ALREADY
AVAILABLE THAT HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
FUNDS. AND WE HAVE A
CONTRACTORS NETWORK IS PRETTY
LARGE IN TERMS OF. ITS
AVAILABILITY TO BRING SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE COMMUNITIES
I OFFER ALSO. ENCOURAGE ARE
SENATE OFFICES WORKING THROUGH
LOCAL NONPROFITS TO COMMUTE
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE
THESE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE UP
PROGRAMS ARE UNDER SUBSCRIBER
I'M WORKING ON A BILL ON
WEATHER IS ATION THAT'LL EXPAND
THE ELIGIBILITY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN DO MORE WEATHER IS
ATION ACROSS THE STATE BECAUSE
IT'S HARDER. AND HARDER TO
AFFORD A HOME THE CALIFORNIA
MUCH MUCH LESS MAKE THESE. FOR
EXPENSIVE IMPROVEMENTS AND WE
HAVE FUNDS AVAILABLE TO DO THAT
WITHOUT INCREASING. THE POOL OF
FUNDS THEY'RE ALREADY AVAILABLE
WOULD JUST INCREASE ELIGIBILITY
AND HELP. MAKE MORE WITH THAT
MAKE SURE WHETHER THEY SHOULD
MORE VILLAGE WANDER THROUGH THE
LITTLE PLUG IN THERE BECAUSE-
THIS BILL IS ALSO COMING TO
THIS COMMITTEE AND A CAR SEAT
WORKS REALLY WELL. WITH. CENTER
BACKERS BILL. ON THE CERES AND
THIS AREA I HOPE THAT WE CAN.
ADVANCE BY HIS BILL- SO BORJA
DID YOU WANT ALSO MAKE. AND
THEN WE HAVE CENTER HERTZBERG.
I WANT TO COMMEND THE OF THE
CENTER FOR MENLO PARK- I
ANTICIPATED THAT. WE WOULD HAVE
SOME PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCES
ON ON THIS ISSUE IN MY
UNDERSTAND THERE'S BEEN. SOME
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS- I WOULD
LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONSULT
WITH SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE
IN OPPOSITION BUT- I THINK
YOU'RE DOING A FANTASTIC JOB
ENGAGING WITH FOLKS ON THIS
ISSUE- ON. I'LL PROBABLY REMAIN
AND NO FOR TODAY BUT- I HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ANOTHER
BITE AT THIS- INOPPORTUNE TO
BETTER APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT COULD VERY
WELL CHANGE BUT FOR RIGHT NOW
JUST ONE JUST LET YOU KNOW. I
RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE DOING. BUT
I'M GONNA. BE RESPECTFUL
OPPONENT JUST FOR TODAY THOUGH
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU
FOR WORK. THANK YOU. TEN
HERTZBERG. I JUST WANT TO SHAKE
MY CAUGHT MY THE POSITION THAT
OF SENATOR DODD OF THE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT AT THE
SAME RESERVATIONS STRESSES IN
ADULT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER STERN. THINGS CHAIR
I JUST JUST WANTED TO GET A
TINY BIT OF CLARITY- FROM THE
AUTHOR GOING FOR MY BIGGEST
CONCERN- WAS THAT THE- SHE WAS
THE INVERSE OF THE SENATOR FROM
GUARDINO IS WHICH WAS NOT THAT
THE BENEFITS- WILL BE OVER
COUNTED BUT THAT THEY'LL BE
UNDERCOUNTED THINGS LIKE
RESILIENCY- THE ABILITY FOR THE
GREAT SAY TO STAY ONLINE AND
WILDFIRE ZONES THAT DAY TO GET
YOU KNOW IT UNDER SOME
DEFINITIONS THAT COULD BE SEEN
AS A NON ENERGY BENEFITS. SO MY
ONLY CONCERN IS THE P. YOU SEE
LOOKS IT DISTRIBUTED GENERATION
AND LOOKS AT SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL VALUES OTHER ISSUES
AROUND FORESTRY OR BIOMASS SOME
OF THESE SOME OF THESE NON
ENERGY BENEFITS MAY BE RELATED
TO YOU KNOW FORCE TO YOUR BIO
MASS BENEFITS TO SOME OF THE
PIECES LOOK AT SOMETIMES IT'S
WILDFIRE IT JUST DEPENDS SO I
APPRECIATE- I THINK I'VE HEARD
WITH IT HEARD THE AUTHORS SAY
MAYBE CAN JUST CLARIFIES THAT.
YOU DON'T WANT THE BILL TO
IMPACT. WHAT THE PUC'S DOING.
ON OTHER FRONTS SAY IT'S A NET
ENERGY METERING OR
INTERCONNECTION OR OTHER ISSUES
THAT YOU'RE SORT OF YOU'RE JUST
TRYING TO STAY WITHIN THE LANE
OF. HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
NON ENERGY BENEFITS ARE
ASSESSED IN THE IN THIS SORT OF
INCENTIVE BASED FRAMEWORK IN MY
HEARING THAT RIGHT. YES ARE YOU
THROUGH THE CHAIR SORRY. YES WE
ARE A FOCUS ON THE BILLION
DOLLARS HAS ALREADY COLLECTED
TODAY AND THROUGH THIS MEASURE
WE DO NOT MEAN TO INADVERTENTLY
TIE AS I SAID TIED THE PUC'S
HANDS. TO INCLUDE YOU KNOW
DETERMINE THE BENEFITS OF
RESILIENCE FOR- ACOSTA TAKEN
STEPS TO SHOULD BE GENERATION
OR ANY OF THAT GOING FORWARD SO
YOU ARE CORRECT. I ALSO THINK
THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
CASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THERE ISN'T ANYONE ELSE-
SENATOR BAKER COULD YOU YOU
WANNA MAKE YOUR CLOSING
COMMENTS SURE I'LL JUST ADDRESS
A FEW OF THE COMMENTS IN MY
CLOTHES I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE AND ALL
THE FOLKS WHO ARE WORKING WITH
US. ON THIS BILL. JUST FOR THE
CENTER FOR GARDENIA THIS.
FEELING AS HE IS THE SHEER
MENTIONS DOES INCLUDE WEATHER
STATION PROGRAM IS A LOOK
FORWARD TO. WORKING WITH HIM
IN. A COLLECTIVELY ON A- ON ON
HIS BILL. THAT I THINK WILL BE-
AGAIN- ADDITIVE TO THIS. AND
THE IDEA IS REALLY JUST YEAR
MORE MONEY. TOWARDS POOR
COMMUNITIES THAT DO GET MORE
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S THE TO GET
MORE BENEFITS. FROM CLEAR PINE
FINANCES FROM SOLAR FROM
WEATHER IS ATION. PROGRAMS
THAT'S REALLY THE ATTENTIVE
AND- AND JUST ADDRESS THE OTHER
CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED AGAIN
THIS IS NOT. GOING TO INCREASE
FEES AT ALL THIS IS NOT
INCREASING RATES AT ALL THIS IS
A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT'S
ALREADY COLLECTED. AND WE ARE
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. HAVE
MORE ACCESS TO THAT MONEY THAT
IS ALREADY CONNECTED. SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK AND FOR
THE OTHER CLARIFICATIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN
WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION FROM THE
FLOOR- WE HAVE A MOTION BY- BY
SENATOR HAGEL MEN AND I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB THREE
FORTY FIVE AYE SENATOR BAKER TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND BE PURCHASED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR WESSEL BY- WESSEL BY VICE
CHAIR DOLLY NO. THANKS DOLLY
NOW SENATOR BAKER. SENATOR
BAKER I SENATE BARGES NO
CENTREBOARD JUST NOW SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR DOT HI
SENATOR DODD AYE SENATOR AIKMAN
HI SENATE EGGMAN I. SENATOR
GONZALEZ HI SENATOR GONZALEZ HI
SENATOR GROW. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR HERTZBERG BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SENATOR MAN.
SHIPCENTER MEN HI SENATOR RUBIO.
THE SENATOR RUBIO I. SENATOR
STERN. STERN AYE SENATOR STERN
I. OKAY THAT BRINGS US TO THE
END OF OUR CALENDAR WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE ROLE ON THE
REMAINING BILLS FOR THE MEMBERS
THAT WERE ABSENT DURING THE
VOTE BUTTON MEANTIME UP WE CAN
ASK THE SURGEON TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BACK TO THE
FLOOR TO. TO ADD ON TO THAT
VOTE IN THE MEANTIME I'D LIKE
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFIED TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD SAY ARE
ACTUALLY ADDED AND THEY ARE
READ SO IF- YOU WISH TO SEND
THE MEN WE HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO SO THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR THE
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME. OF
OUR PRAYERS GO OUT TO ALL THE
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL ADJOURN AFTER THE VOTE.
AFTER THE VOTE SO- IF WE HAVE
EVERYONE ON THE FLOOR NOW WE
WILL NOW CALL THE VOTE ON ALL
THE REMAINING BILLS- WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE S.
B. EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB EIGHTEEN TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON ON
ENVIRONMENTAL. QUALITY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SENATE SENATE MCGUIRE
I. TWELVE AS CHAIR. OKAY THAT
BILL IS UP WILL NOT CLOSE ROLE
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE IS P.
EIGHTEEN THE BILL IS
SUCCESSFULLY OUT NOW WILL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE AND SEVEN
WHICH IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CONSENT
CALENDAR SENATOR DODD. SENATOR
DODD DODD SENATOR DODD I.
SENATOR EGGMAN SENATOR EGGMAN I
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATE MCGUIRE.
SENATE MCGUIRE AYE SENATOR
STERN HI SENATOR STERN I.
UNANIMOUS AT THE CHECK IN A SET
BILLS THAT WILL NOT CLOSE ROLE
WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS
P. TWO EIGHT TWO FOUR BY
SENATOR DODD CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SB TO AFFORD
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR STERN. STERN AYE.
SENATOR STERN I'D- SHARE ALSO
UNANIMOUS ALSO UNANIMOUS A BILL
IS OUT OF WILL CLOSE A ROLL
THIS ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
FORTY ONE BY CENTER MCGUIRE
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB THREE FORTY ONE TO
PASS AS AMENDED SENATOR STERN.
STERN I. SENATOR STERN HI.
THIRTEEN A CIRCUIT THAT BILL IS
OUT WILL CLOSE A ROLL NOW- ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB 3405% BAKER CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SB THREE FORTY FIVE TO PASS AS
AMENDED. SENATOR MCGUIRE HI.
SEVEN REQUIRED BY. TEN AS AND
TO THOSE. VERY WELL THAT BILL
IS OUT AS WELL WILL NOT CLOSE
ROLE THIS WILL OFFICIALLY BRING
ARE SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS TO
FULLER GERMAN. HAVE A GOOD
EVENING EVERYONE.